اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام في حصاد الليله
معكم محمود مراد ونخصص احصاد الليله
لمتابعه اخر التطورات من روسيا وفي مواضيع
الحصاد هذه الليله
وساطه من رئيس بيلاروسيا تنهت صعيدا غير
مسبوق على الساحه الروسيه بعد ساعات من
وصول قوه فاجنر الى ضواحي موسكو وانتشارها
في مدينه روستوف جنوبا وتهديد قائدها
بالاطاحه
منعا لسفك الدماء قواته تبدا في الانسحاب
من روستوف والكريملين يتحدث عن اسقاط
الملاحقه الجنائيه ضده وانه سيغادر الا
بيلاروسيا
[موسيقى]
وفي تداعيات التصعيد بين فاغنر ووزاره
الدفاع الروسيه زيلينسكي يقول ان تمرد
فاغنر يكشف عن فوضى في روسيا وقوته تتحدث
عن تمكنها من اختراق تحصينات روسيه في شرق
اوكرانيا والتقدم على جبهات بخموت وفي
الجوار كازاخستان تستنفر قيادتها الامنيه
لبحث التداعيات وجورجيا تدعو لبحث وضع
اتخازيا واوسيتيا الانفصاليتين
وفي ردود الفعل الدوليه مشاورات بين وزراء
خارجيه مجموعه السبع بشان الوضع في روسيا
رئيس هيئه الاركان الامريكيه يلغي زياره
خارجيه لمتابعه التطورات عن كثب من واشنطن
وواشنطن تؤجل فرض عقوبات على خشيه
اعتبارها منحازه وقلق في بريطانيا من
تداعيات اي تغيير سياسي في روسيا جره
الازمه
[موسيقى]
في اخر التطورات من داخل روسيا اعلن
ايفغيني قائد مجموعه فاجنر قبل قبوله
وساطه الرئيس البيلاروسي وامر قوته
بالعوده الى معسكراتها وبالفعل انتشرت صور
من مدينه روستوف لبدء انسحاب مقاتلي فاجنر
من المدينه كما نشرت وسائل اعلام اخرى
صورا لقوات فاجنر اثناء اعداد دباباتها
للانسحاب من محيط مقر القياده العسكريه
الجنوبيه للمدينه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الروسيه قد اعلن ان قوته ستعود الى
معسكراتها بعد اقترابها من موسكو بمائه
كيلو متر مؤكدا ان القرار اتخذ حقنا
للدماء الروسيه واشار بريجون في
تسجيل صوتي الى ان قطره دم واحده لم تسفك
خلال ما سماه مسيره العداله جاء ذلك بعد
حديث الرئيس البيلاروسي عن تقديم ضمانات
امنيه لبريجوجين عقب وساطه قادها معه
كانت هناك اراده لحل شركه فاجنر العسكريه
الخاصه خرجنا يوم الثالث والعشرين من
يونيو في مسيره العداله خلال يوم واحد
قطعنا طريقا طويلا ولم يعد يفصلنا عن
موسكو سوى 200 كيلومتر خلال هذا الوقت لم
ترك فيها قطره دم واحده من دماء مقاتلينا
لكن حين لاحت لحظه يمكن ان تراك فيها
الدماء وادراكا منا للمسؤوليه الكامله عن
اراقه الدماء الروسيه في صفوف اي من
الطرفين قررنا اعاده قوافلنا والمغادره في
الاتجاه المعاكس الى المعسكرات الميدانيه
حسب الخطه
وقبل قليل اعلن الكريم انه سيتم اسقاط
الدعوه الجنائيه ضد بريكوجن وانه سيغادر
الى بيلاروسيا كما اعلن الكريم عن تقديره
لجهود وساطه الرئيس البيلاروسي كانت
الرئاسه البيلاروسيه قد قالت ان الرئيس
الكسندر لوكيشنكو اجرى اتصالا مع بريجوجل
واضافت الرئاسه البيلاروسيه ان محادثات
لوكاشينكو مع بريكوجين استمرت طوال اليوم
وجرت بالتنسيق مع الرئيس بوتين وانه جرى
خلالها تقديم مقترح لحل الازمه يشمل من
حضمانات امنيه لمقاتلي فاجنا
انقلاب خيانه طعنه في الظهر تهور تعددت
الاوصاف قبل ان يسحب قائد فاجنر قواته الى
معسكراتهم قال يفجعيني بيرجوجين انه اقدم
على تلك الخطوه تجنبا لسفك الدماء وبعد
وساطه رئيس بيلاروسيا بينه وبين الرئيس
بوتين من حليف للجيش الروسي في الجبهات
الاماميه لمعركه بخموت في اوكرانيا الى
عدو يهدد بالاطاحات بالمؤسسه العسكريه
لبلاده يفجن بريكوجين يخلط الاوراق
والحسابات بسرعه تجعل فهم ما يجري امرا
عسيرا ومن مساء الجمعه الى السبت حدثت
تطورات كثيره وخطيره لن تنتهي بازاله
اللوحه الدعائيه لفاجنر في شوارع المدن
الروسيه موسكو تحت نظام عمليه مكافحه
الارهاب انتشار للجيش في الشوارع ونقاط
تفتيش وتعليق لحركه الملاحه في نهر
موسكوبا
للمواطنين بالبقاء في منازلهم وعدم الخروج
الا للضروره القصوى تهديدات الجمعه
بالاطاحه بالقياده العسكريه والزحف من
اوكرانيا الى روسيا لم تكن مجرد كلام
فعلها ودخل مدينه روسطو تباها بانجازه
قائلا انه لم يطلق رصاصه واحده خلال
سيطرته على مركز العمليات العسكريه الروسي
الرئيسي وقاعده جويه في المدينه توعد
بالوصول الى موسكو للاطاحه بكبار القاده
العسكريين الذين يتهمهم باستهداف وقتل
مقاتله سرعان ما وجه الرئيس فلاديمير
بوتين خطابا للامه حذر فيه من التهديد
القاتل وخطر اندلاع حرب اهليه على يد قائد
مجموعه فاجنر
اولئك الذين نظموا وحضروا لتمرد عسكري
واولئك الذين حملوا السلاح ضد رفاقهم في
القتال خان روسيا وسيحاسبون على خي اتوجه
لاولئك الذين يتم اقحامهم في هذه الجريمه
واطلبوا منهم عدم ارتكاب خطا قاتل وماساوي
رفض الاستسلام الطوعي له ولمقاتليه واسهب
في انتقاد النظام الحالي
فيما يتعلق بخيانه الوطن الرئيس مخطئ نحن
وطنيون كنا ولا نزال نحارب ولا احد يعتزم
الاستسلام بطلب من الرئيس او جهاز امن
الدوله او اي كان لاننا لا نريد ان تستمر
بلادنا بالحياه بهذه الطريقه في ظل الفساد
والكذب والبيروقراطيه
للتذكير من يتحدث عن الفساد هو رجل قضى
فتره طويله في السجن قبل ان يفتح مطعما
بسيطا للنقانق ثم سلسله مطاعم تقدمه
خدماتها للرئاسه والجيش حتى اصبح يلقب
بطباخ الكريم ربما اخر ما كان يتوقعه
بوتين هو ان يسمم هذا الحليف السابق الوضع
الامني في روسيا في اوجه حرب اوكرانيا
المصيريه لموسكو وخلال اليوم وصلت القوات
الشيشانيه التي ارسلها الرئيس قديروف لقمع
التمرد على حد وصفه مع مرور الوقت طالت
قائمه القرارات والاجراءات التي اتخذها
الكرملين لحمايه العاصمه وباقي مناطق
البلاد من دخول قوات فاجنر معركه بوتين
بريكوجين غموض في غموض هل هي فعلا ضربه
موجعه لموسكو في توقيت غير مناسب لحظات
انتشاء وشماته حلفاء كييف لم تدوم سوى
ساعات والسؤال الاهم هل بانسحاب قوات
فاجنر الى معسكراتهم تكون هذه هي نهايه
هذه الدراما الروسيه ام هي البدايه فقط
معنى من موسكو مدير مكتب الجزيره زاور
شاوج زوار يوم طويل في حياه روسيا ربما
والاخطر والاكثر ذخرا وملئا بالاحداث
الملفته للنظر الذي تابعها العالم كله اذا
اردنا ان نجم الاحداث هذا اليوم من اين
نبدا تحديدا
محمود كان يمكن ان يكون نهايته ان تكون
نهايه هذا اليوم طويل ترايجديه لو وصل
القوات فاقدر الى العاصمه الروسيه واصطدمت
مع تلك القوه العسكريه التي
كانت منتشره من اجل الدفاع عن العاصمه
الروسيه او كان هناك مواجهات مباشره بين
القوات الشيشانيه وقوات فاجنر في مدينه
راستوف لا احد كان سيعرف الى اين ستتجه
الامور ولكن
الوساطه التي قام بها الرئيس البيلاروسي
واضح انها
[موسيقى]
جاءت بنتيجه نتيجه نتيجه ربما دفعت الشارع
الروسي لتنفس السعداء قليلا في ظرف صعب
معقد تمر بها البلاد نتيجه الحرب في
اوكرانيا وايضا هذا
التمرد كما سماه الكرمله تمرد العسكري
الذي قام به
وقوات فاغنر ولكن
بدانا وانشاء المختصر عما جرى كان هناك
قرار
دخول الاراضي الروسيه باعتقال الوزير
الدفاع وقائد الاركان بسبب ما قال بريجوجل
حسب روايته انه تم استهداف معسكرات قوات
فاجنر داخل دومباس كان هناك
تطور وتصعيد سريع وبدون اي مقاومه فعليه
من الجيش الروسي على الرغم من ان هناك
اسقاط لبعض المروحيات هناك خمسه عشر قاتله
روسيا
معظمهم سقطوا في احدى الطائرات النقل
العسكريه التي استهدفت استهدفت قوات فاجنر
عندما
دفع
بقواته باتجاه موسكو كنا هنا بانتظار
المواجهه مواجهه حتميه سيما وان القوات
الروسيه هنا في داخل المدينه وسلطات
الروسيه في العاصمه موسكو اعلنت حاله
اتاهب وحاله مكافحه الارهاب ولكن في
اللحظه الحاسمه يبدو ان الرئيس لوكاشنكا
لديه اوراق ضغط تواصلت خلاله
قوات فاجنر مع القياده الروسيه الى صفقه
في البدايه في الولايه الاولى محمود كان
الكل ينظر الى هذا الاتفاق على انه تنازل
كبير من الرئيس الروسي ولكن الان الكريندن
يحاول وضع النقاط على الحروف فيما جرى وفي
ضوء هذا الاتفاق قائد قوات فاجر سيتجه
وسيغادر الى بيلاروسيا هذا يعني انه يخرج
من المشهد السياسي والعسكري في اوكرانيا
وفي روسيا ايضا وهو لديه املاك ولديه راس
مال كبير هنا في الاراضي الروسيه الشيء
الاخر مصير قوات فاجر من الواضح من خلال
تصريحات
لن تعود الى شكلها السابق من لم يدخل في
هذه المواجهه سيوقع عقودا مع وزاره الدفاع
وبالتالي سيقاتل تحت قياده وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه اما من شارك في هذا التصعيد الذي
جرى اليوم لن تتم لح قانونيا ولهذا في ضوء
الاتفاقيات وقعت اليوم الرئيس الروسي على
قانون
يلغي الملاحقه القضائيه بحق من ارتكب
اعمالا من المتطوعين او من الذين تم
استدعائهم للتعبئه الجزئيه
بسبب بفضل مشاركته في العالم العمليه
العسكريه وبفضل اداء قوات فاقذر
القوي خلال العمليه العسكريه فلن تم تتم
ملاحقه ملاحقه اجراء اي ملاحقات قضائيه
بحق اولئك الذين دخلوا الى الاراضي
الروسيه ولكن يبقى السؤال الى اين سيذهب
اولا هؤلاء هل سيسلمون على السي حتى هم هل
سيغادرون ايضا الى بيلاروسيا هل سيعودون
الى افريقيا التي جاء قسم كبير منهم
والذين كانوا يخدمون هناك ضمن قوات فاكتور
اذن فعليا بشكل او باخر على الاقل في ضوء
القراءه الاوليه لهذا الاتفاق فان مستقبل
فاكتور اصبح واضح نعم قدم التنازلات هو
براي كثيرين الان جنب روسيا حربا اهليه
جنب المواجهه العسكريه كان لدى القوات
الروسيه القدره وهذا كان السؤال الابرز
محمودنا في روسيا لماذا لم تقصف القوات
الروسيه قوات فاقدر وهي في طريق مفتوح في
اوتوستراد فعليا اخليه من كل المواصلات
العامه من الكل المواصلات الخاصه
واصبح على بعد اقل من 200 كيلو متر عن
موسكو حتى بعض القوات وصلت الى الضواحي او
لمقاطعه موسكو وهي يعني على بعد تقريبا
مسافه 100 كلم من العاصمه الروسيه ولكن من
الواضح ان هناك بعض التنازلات من قبل
القياده الروسيه ولكن في المحصله يبدو ان
الانتصار كان للرئيس الروسي في حسم مستقبل
فاقدر كمؤسسه عسكريه طبعا في الايام
القادمه محمود سنعرف هل سيبقى هذا التنظيم
هذه الجماعه هذه الشركه في نفس الشكل
التنظيمي الذي كانت الموجوده فيه السؤال
الابرز الابرز الثاني عفوا هو مستقبل وزير
الدفاع ومستقبل قائد على الاركان هاتان
الشخصيتان محمود اختفى اليوم من المشهد
منذ اندلاع الازمه مساء الامس حتى حتى سخر
بريغوجي من القائد الاركان بانه فر من
مدينه عندما اقتربت منها قوات فاجذر عند
في ظل هذه الازمه يختفي او تختفي اهم
شخصيتين في المؤسسه العسكريه الروسيه هذا
امر ايضا ربما يفتح التساؤلات حول مستقبل
شيكو وجراسي في هرم السلطه العسكريه
الروسيه زور شاوج مدير مكتب الجزيره في
موسكو شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه يوم
عصيب مر على روسيا كان بطل احداثه في جيني
بريجوجن قائده ومالك قوات الشركه فاجنر
وذلك بعد اعلانه التمرد على الجيش الروسي
واعتزامه الزحفه الى موسكو فبعد ساعات
عصيبه
فيها ان مخرج من المواجهه وحسم التمرد
بحسب تاكيدات الرئيس
قرر التراجع عن مخططه ووقف التقدم الى
موسكو ضمن قائد فاجنر سلامته وسلامه جنوده
واسقاط الجرم عنه لكن روسيا ستلاحقه ازمه
الاداء العسكري او ستلاحق روسيا ازمه
الاداء العسكري في حرب تاخذ كل يوم شكلا
من اشكال الاستنزاف وكانها تعيد سيره حرب
اخرى خاضتها موسكو في افغانستان انتهت قصه
فاجنر وبقيت عبرتها لروسيا ولغيرها تقرير
فوزي بشرى
انها البنادق غير المؤتمنه تعيش في كنف
الجيوش الرسميه حينا من الزمن ثم ما اسرع
ما تتوجه فوهاتها الى صدور من صنعها روسيا
اليوم في هول من مشهد استداره بنادق باجنر
الى القوات المسلحه الروسيه في لحظه من
اكثر ازمنه روسيا بوتين حرجا وانفتاحا على
سيناريوهات تتصل باسئله وجوديه قاسيه
روسيا المنخرطه في حرب في اوكرانيا تقول
انها تخوضها في الواقع ضد حلف الناتو
المتورط فيها تمويلا وتسليحا ودعما فنيا
في خضم هذه الحرب التي تشهد تقدم للقوات
الاوكرانيه في هجوم واسع مكنها من استعاده
بعض ما فقدت من اراضي في هذا الوقت الحارج
من سير المعركه يقرر مالك شركه باجنر
يبكيين سحب قواته ومغادره ارض المعركه الى
داخل روسيا
تدخل قواته مدينه روستوف في الجنوب الروسي
وتقول انها استولت على المقر العسكريه
وانها في طريقها الى موسكو الماساه في هذه
الدراما الروسيه هي ان زعيم باقنر
بريكوجين هو من عول عليه بوتين في تغيير
معدله الحرب برجاله البالغ عددهم 25 الف
مقاتل
ابلا رجالوفاجنر في الحرب ورجال فاغنر كما
يصفهم الاعلام الروسي اليوم ليسوا سوى
مجرمين سابقين ومغامرين يدخلون الحرب من
اجل الكسب كما يدخلون ناديا للقمار حيث
الربح والخساره
يتارجحان يتارجح الموت والحياه في الحرب
ولان المال والعتاد والذخائر هي شرط
البنادق المستاجره فقد خرج بريجوجين يصب
قياده الجيش الروسي ممثلا في كبار القاده
ابتداء من وزير الدفاع
ورئيس هيئه الاركان فاليري
محملا اياهم الاداء البائسه للقوات
الروسيه في الحرب ثم هدد رئيس فاجنر
بالانسحاب من جبهه القتال متهما وزير
الدفاع بانه امر الجيش بفتح النار على
جنوده ثم بدا لرئيس باجنر ان اخراج
الروسيا الى بر الامان لا يكون الا
بتجريده عسكريه الى موسكو والتحرك الى
موسكو بالغا ما بلغت قوه فاجنر سيكون عملا
انتحاريا الا اذا كان تحركا ضابنا لاسناد
كبير من قاده الجيش وهذا سيناريو اذا حدث
فسيحيل الى شيء واحد هو الانقلاب على
بوتين فهل تمت تواطؤ بين قطاع من الجيش مع
فاجنر وهل يقبل المزاج العام في روسيا
صعود هذه المجموعه الى سده الحكم في موسكو
ايا ما بلغت ضيق بسياسات بوتين في الحرب
وغير الحرب هل يملك زعيم مناصرين في
الطبقه السياسيه في الكريملين وخارجه وهل
الحديث يفقيني عن ثوره شعبيه كبرى في
روسيا بسبب الحرب هو ضرب من التحريض وحمل
الناس على الاعتقاد بالحاجه الى هذه
الثوره هكذا فكر
ثم عاد فراجع حساباته فاثر السلامه في
لعبه للقوه بدت الخسائر فيها اوضح من
المكاسب فقال انه امر جنوده بالعوده من
الزحف الى موسكو وكان بوتين الماخوذ بتمرد
قائد فاجنر عليه وصف الامر بانه طعنه في
الظهر لروسيا وان سلوك بريكوجين يمثل
خيانه للبلاد وان التعامل معه سيكون قاسيا
وحاسما فليس من هدن هنا ولا من مسطاها لا
خير في كثير من نجواهم يوم ثقيل على روسيا
واثقل منهما سياتي بعده في بلد يخوض حربا
ضد اوكرانيا التي تقف من خلفها امم من
خلفها امم وتحارب في الان نفسه عدو من بني
جلدتها كانت تظنه حتى امس حمايتها ودعمها
السريع ساعه فزعه درس اخر في عدم الركون
الى التنظيمات العسكريه غير الرسميه
فوالاؤها دائما لبنادقها المتخففه من ثقل
الافكار والقيم فلبعد من الرشيط واسع من
التدخلات غير الحميده في العالم لا سيما
في افريقيا حيث تبيع البنادق وتبيع معها
الايادي القاتله كذلك مثل ما حدث في ليبيا
وافريقيا الوسطى والسودان وغيرها من
البلدان بتكلفه عاليه ستحاول روسيا القضاء
على فاجنر التي بدا فعلها في ظل الحرب
الدائره وكانه محاوله تفجير للقلعه
الروسيه من الداخل
اوكرانيا والغرب جميعهم يتابعون ما يحدث
في روسيا وفي موسكو تحديدا فرئيس فاجنر
يفغيني بريكو جين الملقب بطباخ بوتين يقدم
طبقه الاخير لصديقه الرئيس بوتين منهيا
مقوله الخبز والملح
تنضموا الينا من موسكو اولغا كراسي نياك
استاذه العلاقات الدوليه بجامعه الابحاث
الوطنيه السيده كراسينيات مرحبا بك في
الوقت الراهن يعني لنبدا بالسؤال الاخير
الذي طرحه مراسلنا قبل قليل كيف وصلت قوات
قوامها 25 الف في اقصى تقدير هو حجم قوات
افاجنر الى تخوم العاصمه موسكو في بلد هو
يملك اكبر ترسانا نوويه في العالم وثاني
اكبر جيش او ثاني اقوى جيش في العالم
تقريبا الى اي مدى يكشف هذا اما هشاشه
الوضع الامني او ان الرجل تلقى ضمانات
بعدم قصفه في طريق ام اربعه
المفتوح الذي كان يسير فيه بكل حريه دون
ان تطلق عليه رصاصه
هذا سؤال وجيه لكن بالتاكيد الامر لا
يتعلق
بمساله
تهديد روسيا او القضاء على روسيا قوه
نوويه او حيازتها
لترسانه النوويه لان هذا الامر حصل منذ
يوم الامس ومن الجيد انه تم حله القضيه
الاساسيه هنا ان مجموعه فاقنار ووزير
الدفاع وكل القوات الروسيه لدينا هدف
مشترك لدينا
طموح مشترك وبالتالي فهذه الحاله حتى حصلت
هذه الحادثه والتي سيتم النظر اليها
لكنها بالتاكيد لا يمكن ان تضر بصوره
روسيا او تقترح ان هنالك خلل او هشاشه في
امكانيات روسيا طيله خمسه اشهر والتصريحات
القاسيه تصدر من
بحق وزير الدفاع وبحق رئيس هيئه الاركان
والرئيس فلاديمير بوتين يتفرج في صمت دون
ان يتدخل
للحيلوله دون وقوع ما بدا وكانها ازمه
واضحه للعيان ستنفجر في اي لحظه وحين تدخل
الرئيس وحين تكلم الرئيس بعد اعلان ما سمي
او ما وصف بالتمرد لم يسمي بريجوجن باسمه
وانما قال انه اصدر فقط اوامره بصد هذا
التمرد وامر بالملاحقه القضائيه لهذا
الرجل الذي قاد اخطر يوم في تاريخ روسيا
الحديث ربما الذي كان يفترض انه في
التقييم المبدئي يهدد وجود الدوله الروسيه
كيف نفهم هذا
بالتاكيد
فيما يتعلق في الاشهر السابقه عندما كان
يشتكي بريكوجن حول مساله تجهيزي
المدفعيه والمعدات القتاليه
الثقيله هو انتقد وزير الدفاع ولكن كما
ذكرت فان الرئيس بوتين ربما لم يلاحظ ولم
يذكر اي شيء علنا بالتالي لا نعرف حقا ما
الذي حدث في الاتصالات والاحاديث الداخليه
اذا لم يعلن شيء لا يعني انه القضيه قد
تمت قد تم تجاهل تجاهلها او ان السلطات لم
تاخذ الامر بنظر الاعتبار لكن علينا ان
نعترف انه كان هنالك توتر موجود ولربما
بعض
بدا ظهور مؤشرات حقيقيه لهذا التوتر لكن
الامر لا يتعلق
المواجهه المباشره بين بريكوجين والرئيس
بوتين بالتاكيد ان ايا منهما لم يؤشر
مباشره الى الاخر بالتالي قد يكون هنالك
مساله طموحات شخصيه لدى ربما دوافع شخصيه
دفعته للقيام مقام به اليوم لكن اذا لم
يتم مناقشه الشيء كما قلت لا يعني انه قد
تم تجاهله يعني مساله الدوافع الشخصيه
والطموح السياسيه للرجل مثل بريجوجين كيف
اذا كانت هناك يعني دوافع من هذا القبيل
كيف تخلى الرجل عن كل هذه الاحلام فجاه في
غضون اقل من 24 ساعه ثم يعني كيف كيف نفهم
ايضا وهذه طبعا ازمه غير مسبوقه في تاريخ
روسيا تفتح الباب لكل الاسئله فاجد نفسي
يعني او اجد يجد المتابعون حريه في طرح
السؤال الرئيس بوتين الذي هو قادم اصلا
اصلا من اروقه جهاز المخابرات الكي جي بي
القوي وكذلك الذي له تجربه سابقه في
الخداع الاستراتيجي حينما اكد اكثر من
مرات عديده انه لن يدخل بقواته الى
اوكرانيا ثم دخل الى اوكرانيا بعد ان حشد
الكثيرين على الحدود لماذا لا تذهب
التفسيرات الى ان هذا الامر بالترتيب مع
الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين للتخلص من بعض
مراكز القوى داخل المؤسسه العسكريه هل
تستبعدين ذلك
بنظر الاعتبار الخلفيه الرئيس بوتين
ايضا فهذا امر محتمل لكن كما قلت فاننا
كان هنالك مراقبه للوضع منذ يوم امس تم
ايجاد حل بشكل ناجع
لامه الروسيه وللشعب الروسي بوقت قصر اذا
ما نظرنا الى النتائج فقط نرى ان الامر
كان ناجحا بالتالي لما يلحق احد الاذى ولم
يكن هنالك اي صعوبات مواجهه اي شخص
بالتالي في هذه الحاله اعتقد انه كان قد
تم اجراء محادثات داخليه قد لا نعرف عنها
واعتقد انها حصلت بالتاكيد وكما ذكرت
وذكرت ايضا انا في السابق حول مساله طموح
المطامح السياسيه هذه فقط تكهنات لا نعرف
بالتاكيد اذا
حقيقه ما حدث علينا ان ننتظر لكن بالتاكيد
فان السيده بريكوجين الان قد تم اعاده
قد ارسل الى بيلاروسيا الان لكن فيما
يتعلق
وحده الشعب الروسي والسياسه الخارجيه
وايضا سياسه
روسيا في منطقه في فتره الصراع الامر لم
يتغير ويبدو لي ان الامور ستم ستسير بشكل
ناجحنا شكرا جزيلا لك يا السيده اولغا
استاذه العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه الابحاث
الوطنيه كانت معنا من موسكو رحبوا بضيفي
من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي سياده اللواء مرحبا
بك اذا استسلمنا لظاهر الامور دون الغوص
في تفاصيل ما يمكن ان يوصف بمؤامرات او
ترتيبات
ظاهر الامور يقول ان مجموعه مسلحه قوامها
على اقصى تقدير 25 الف مقاتل توغلت في
الجغرافيا الروسيه الرهيبه في اكبر دوله
في العالم مساحتها تزيد عن 17 مليون كيلو
متر مربع ووصلت الى تخوم العاصمه موسكو
دون ان يطلق عليها طلقه واحده وان سحبت
بكل بساطه هكذا ما الذي تفهمه من هذا
السيناريو هل يشي بوجود هشاشه امنيه شديده
في الدوله الروسيه ام هناك ترتيبات لا
ندري عنها شيئا
يعني كل الاحتمالات كلا الاحتمالين يمكن
الحديث به ويمكن ان تجد له المبررات ولكن
دعنا اتوقف عند الاحتمال الاول الذي يتم
التركيز عليه اولا روسيا كما اشرت ثاني
جيش في العالم مليون ومئه وخمسين الف قبل
التعبئه الجزئيه
لديه 24 الف دبابه
الاف المدفعيات الاف الطائرات العموديه
والمقاتله ثاني جيش في العالم ولكن هذا
الجيش الذي كان مقدرا له ان يواجه حلف
النيتو
لم ينجح في الحرب ضد اوكرانيا وترتيبها
متاخر جدا بالنسبه لها الجيوش العالميه لا
بل
عانى من ثلاثه انتكاسات مما افضى الى
توظيفي فاجنر
لتنفذ الاعمال التي عجز الجيش الروسي عن
تنفيذها وقلنا كثيرا ان الجيش الروسي
يعاني انا قلت لك لدي 24 الف لغه دباب لغه
ارقام منها اكثر من
6500 دبابه تي اربعه وخمسين تي 56 خرجت من
الخدمه في الحرب العالميه الثانيه انا هنا
لا احاول ان اضعف او اقلل من هيبه الجيش
الروسي ولكن الارقام التي تذكر عن الجيش
الروسي لا تعكس واقع ذلك الجيش الان
كيف دخل من اوكرانيا الى ريستور كيف تحرك
مسافه 800 كم باتجاه موسكو المسافه الى
موسكو 1474 كيلو متر كيف تحرك اين الجيش
الروسي اين حرس الحرس الوطني اين القوات
الخاصه اين قياده العمليات الخاصه اين
سلاح
الجو الروسي او القوه يطلق عليها قوات
الفضاء والطائرات العموديه
هناك كان خللا في المنظومه الامنيه اذا
سلمنا بان لم يكن الجيش الروسي غير قادر
على مواجهه هذه المجاميع المتحركه فكان
هناك شبه تسيب امني فراغ امني تحركت هذه
المجموعه بمنتهى الاريحيه مسافه 800 كيلو
متر ومن ثم قام رئيس بيلارو البيلاروسي
بنزع فتيل الازمه الان هناك تحليلات قد لا
نتفق معها قد نتحفظ على بعضها ان كل ما
جرى هو عباره عن تسجيل مواقف لاحداث
مستقبليه قد لا يؤخذ بها في الوقت الحالي
ما لم تتكشف الامور ويصعب الخوض بها لكن
اقول انت التي قام بها هذا الخبر العاجل
الذي ورد على التوة ويظهر على شاشاتنا
الان نقلا عن وكاله انترفيكس الروسيه
تغادر مقر القياده العسكريه الموجود في
روستوف تغادر بكامل اعتادها والياتها هذا
المقر تفضل سياده اللواء
يعني السيده هذا الخبر العاجل هو يعني لا
يمكن اسقاطه على ما قبل الاتفاق ما بعد
الاتفاق هناك ضمانات هناك ضبانه ضمانات
لمن لم يشترك وهناك عمليه توقيع عقود لمن
لم يشارك في المسيره وهل المسيره هي في
الرزق بالمقصود بها الى ريستوف ام
الريستوف الى موسكو اذا هذه تفصيلات تتضح
خلال الساعات والايام القادمه لكن ما
اقوله ان القرار الذي اتخذه بريجوجن لا
اعتقد انه اتخذه من فراغ اتخذه بناء على
مخاطره شبه محسوبه وليست محسوبه بالمطلق
يبدو انه كان يراهن على كثير من العوامل
اولا هناك العديد من الجرارات المتقاعدين
يعملوا تحت امرته في قوات فاجنر ولديهم
امتداد امتدادات في الوحدات التي كانوا
يخدموا بها وي ان لديهم معلومات ان هذه
الوحدات كانت ستدعم هذا التوجه كان لديه
شعبيه لا اقول طاغيه ولكن شعبيه خاصه بعد
معركه باخموت وخلالها ارتفعت واصبحت واصبح
اسمه مادي شبه يوميه في الاعلام الروسي
وبالتالي البعض ذهب بعيدا انه قد يكون
بديل الرئيس بوتين في الانتخابات القادمه
ولكن يبدو هو يعني اولا العلاقه الشخصيه
الاداء الميداني
الحديث عن
الشعبيه له كل ذلك جعله يتحرك وكانه كان
يتوقع من الرئيس بوتين ان يصطف الى جانبه
ولكن حساباته لم تكن دقيقه لانه لا يمكن
ان يوضع في كافه ميزان موازي الى الجيش
الروسي شكرا جزيلا لك سياده اللواء فايز
الدويري الخبير العسكري الاستراتيجي كان
معنا من عمان
الرئيس الاوكراني فلاديمير زيلينسكي كانت
له تصريحات عديده على مدار اليوم تفاعل
فيها مع الاحداث في روسيا زيلينسكي قال ان
تمرد عناصر مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه كشف عن
فوضى كامله في روسيا واضاف ان بلاده لم
تصمت ولن تقف مكتفه الايدي كما انها قادره
على حمايه اوروبا من الشر والفوضى الروسيه
حسب تعبيره
اليوم هو يوم لا ينبغي ان يكون فيه صمت
بالتاكيد ونحن بالتاكيد بحاجه الى قياده
راى العالم اليوم ان ساده روسيا لا
يسيطرون على اي شيء لا شيء على الاطلاق
ببساطه فوضى كامله والافتقار الى اي
امكانيه للتنبؤ
تثير التطورات في روسيا انشغال دول الجوار
حيث دعت جورجيا الى بحث وضع اتخاذيه
واوسيتيا الانفصاليتين وذكرت وزاره
الداخليه البيلاروسيه انها تتابع عن كثب
الاوضاع في روسيا وان قواتها تنفذ خدمتها
بالتوافق مع سير الاحداث من جانبه قال
مكتب الرئيس الكازاخستاني قاسم تكيف ان
الرئيس عقد اجتماع لمناقشه المخاطر التي
تواجه بلاده بسبب الوضع في روسيا
ينضم الينا من وارسو الجنرال المتقاعد
يارسلاف نائب رئيس مديريه الاستخبارات في
حلف الناتو سابقا ومدير الابحاث السابق في
المخابرات العسكريه البولنديه سيد مرحبا
بك ما حجم الضرر الذي لحق بالمؤسسه
العسكريه الروسيه في تقديرك بعد هذه
العمليه التي استغرقت يوما كاملا
وشكلت خطوره او شكلت خطرا على وجود الدوله
الروسيه نفسها فيما هو ظاهر من الاحداث
طبعا واثر ذلك على العمليات العسكريه
الدائره في اوكرانيا في تقديرك
ما هذا الشعور قويه جدا بالتاكيد فان
القوات الروسيه قد خسرت بعض الامكانيات
الهليكوبترات
والطائرات لكنها اعداد متواضعه في نفس
الوقت
هنالك تاثير مره اخرى على الروح المعنويه
وعلى الحاله النفسيه
للجنود الروس وعلى طريقه اداء وزاره
الدفاع
لنشاطاتها حتى كبار الضباط الان راوا ان
الوضع
بالتالي انهم حسوا انهم قد لا يرغبون
باتباع اوامر الرئيس بوتين وهذا بالتالي
ربما خطوه اخرى في تصب في مساله اضعاف في
امكانياتي القوات الروسيه كيف تفسر الصعود
السريع والانسحاب السريع اقصد التقدم
السريع نحو موسكو من قبل قوات فاجنر
والتراج ع السريع والانسحاب ايضا في اقل
من 24 ساعه
نعم نعم الوضع غريب للغايه اعتقد ان هذا
الامر كله مفبرك من قبل
كان مهيا ومخططا لا هو اعداءه الاساسيون
ما يزالونهم وزير دفاع شويغو ورئيس هيئه
الاركان المشتركه جنرال غراسموف بالتالي
هذاني الشخصان كانهما الهدف الاساسي وراء
هذه العمليه نعرف من الاسابيع السابقه
وخاصه ان وزير الدفاع شوي كان هو المعارض
والمعارض والمناوله لبريكوجين بعض الحلقات
في روسيا لا ليست راضيه عن
مساله تطور العمليه العسكريه الخاصه في
اوكرانيا بالتالي هم يريدون ان يحدثوا
تغييرا وهنالك ايضا يعرفون عن الاختلاف
بين الرجلين
وايضا اتوقع انه ربما بعض الجنرالات
الكبار
والمسؤولين الكبار ربما قد سيخسرون
مناصبهم خلال الايام القادمه الرئيس بوتين
سينتهز هذه الفرصه
لتنظيف بعض الاشخاص ادارتي من بعض الاشخاص
بالتالي هذا لكنه في نفس الوقت هو يتمتع
بقوه ونفوذ وامكانيات في مساله اداره
المعارك في اوكرانيا
سيلظف ادارته او حكومته او سلطته من بعض
الاشخاص هل تقصد بذلك وزير الدفاع ورئيس
الاركان
نعم نعم اعتقد ان هذان الشخصان سيكونان
اول من سيتم طردهما من قبل الرئيس بوتين
وان هذا هو جزء من الاتفاق ربما بين
الرئيس بوتين
عبر رئيس بيلاروسيا لوشنكو مع بريكوجين
بالتالي هذان الشخصان اعتقد ان حسب يعتقد
ان ما سيخسراني
منصبهما هم سيقدمان استقالتهما وسيتم
تعيينهم ربما في مهمات اخرى بعد ان بعد
اعطائهم راحه لمده معينه هل هل تعتقد
بوقوع ضرر ما على الدوله الروسيه يعني
الان
جورجيا تتحدث عن وضع اوسيتيا الجنوبيه
وابخزيا الانفصاليتين
والرئيس
طيله اليوم يقول ان روسيا في فوضى وان
غادر موسكو وانه خائف وما الى ذلك بما
يعني انه قد يكون هناك تجرا على الدوله
الروسيه القويه خلال الفتره المقبله اذا
استطعنا ان ندخل الى عقل الرئيس بوتين
واطلعنا على ما يفكر فيه في تقديرك كيف
وما الوسائل التي سيلجا اليها
لاحتواء هذه الاضرار
نعم بعض الاشخاص ولربما هذا هو السبب لهذه
العمليه كما ذكرت قد تكون هذه العمليه
كلها مخطط لها ومفبركه لانه يريد ان يعرف
من الذي سيتخذ الخطوه القادمه مثل افلام
المافيا والعصابات ان تقوم بالتنبؤ
بالخطوه القادمه من عدوك بالتالي الرئيس
بوتين الان بامكانه ان يرى من يقف ضده
ولربما ايضا كان بطريقه ما هي عمليه خداع
ضد اوكرانيا
لربما دفعي اوكرانيا بان تتخذ خطوات
عسكريه لرؤيه اي اتجاه
سيتخذونه في حاله
تشققين بوجود ضعف بالقوات العسكريه
الروسيه ربما بالتاكيد جورجيا قد تكون
منطقه اخرى قد تبدا بالتفكير
خطوات نحو بعض المناطق فيها في اتخاذ نوع
من الاستقلاليه في لكن هذا امر غير محتمل
بدايه لدينا اوكرانيا الحرب في اوكرانيا
وهذا شيء
كان
ينتظر رئيس بوتين الهجمه المضاده الاساسيه
وكان يريد ان يعرف من اين ستاتي الجنرال
المتقاعديه
نائب رئيس مديريه الاستخبارات في حلف
الناتو سابقا والمدير السابق للابحاث في
المخابرات العسكريه البولنديه شكرا جزيلا
لك على هذه المشاركه انضموا الينا من
واشنطن الدكتور خليل العناني استاذ العلوم
السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه دكتور خليل
مرحبا بك
في يعني في تقديرك كيف
كان قصور المخابرات الغربيه وعلى راسها
مخابرات الولايات المتحده الامريكيه عن
التنبؤ وتوقع حدث بمثل هذه الضخامه يجري
في بلد محطوط في موضوع في بؤره اهتمام
الدوائر المخابرات الغربيه بهذه الصوره
هناك بعض التقارير استاذ محمود تتحدث عن
وجود بعض التقارير الاستخباراتيه التي
ظهرت قبل ايام تتحدث عن وجود نوايا على
الاقل لدى رئيس حركه
حول امكانيه التمرد على القاده الروسيه
وبالتالي هناك يعني حاله تجاهل لكن ايضا
ربما كان التحرك اليوم وتحرك مفاجئ للجميع
نتيجه لوجود حلقه من انخراط في الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا ووجود ما يسمى به
الهجوم المضاد الاوكراني على روسيا والذي
كان تم تاجيره يبدا في الربيع قبل شهرين
ثم تم تاجيله حتى على سبيع الماضيه
وبالتالي كانت هناك يعني رغبه امريكيه
اوروبيه فيما يتعلق بدعم هذا الهجوم حتى
يتم التحقيق بعد الانتصارات على الارض
اكثر من اي امر اخر لكن بشكل عام بلا شك
هناك حاله صدمه حاليا او على الاقل حاله
ترقب في الغرب هناك حاله حضر شديد مما
يحدث الان في روسيا على من طرف او من جهه
هناك مخاط يؤدي الصراع داخل روسيا الى
حاله من الانقسام على وبالتالي نتحدث عن
اكبر او عدد اكبر القوه النوويه في العالم
وبالتالي قد يكون هناك مخاطره على استخدام
اللجوء بعد الفصائل المنشقه سواء في الجيش
الروسي او نفسها تسيطر على هذه الاسلحه
النوويه الامر التالي هناك حاله بهجه او
فرح مشروب بحذر بان هذا الامر قد يؤدي ضعف
سلطه بوتين هل يعتبر اكبر تحدي لبوتين منذ
وصول السلطه عام 99 فيما يتعلق بالتمرد
الداخلي حتى تلاحظ هناك طبعا طاقه التمرد
هناك عوده مره اخرى لكن ايضا يمثل جرس
انذار كبير جدا هناك
تقديرات اوروبيه وامريكيه تقول بانه كنت
قد يخرج منها هذه المساله باحث سيناريوهين
اما يخرج بشكل ضعيف او كاسد مجروح
وبالتالي يقوم بمحاوله الانتقام داخل
اوكرانيا او يقوم بمحاوله استخدام هذا ما
حدث اليوم من اجل سحب قواته بشكل او اخر
من الحدود الغربيه لروسيا الشرقيه
الاوكرانيه وبالتالي هناك حتى هذه اللحظه
على الاقل تقديرات متفاوته بين طرفين
الاوروبي والامريكي
قد يكون مرد هذا التفاوت في تحليل الاحداث
الايرباك الذي حدث بسبب التقدم السريع
لفاجنر وربما فرح بعض الدوائر الغربيه بان
هذا قد يخلط اوراق العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه في اوكرانيا ثم التراجع السريع
ايضا لفاجنر
وما ادى اليه من من ربما الارتباك في
مساله تحليل كل هذه العمليه من مبداها الى
منتهى هل هذا صحيح
لم اسمع السؤال يبدو ان نتقاطع في
الانترنت فلو تكرمت ثمره اخرى انا سالتك
عن فرح بعض الدوائر الغربيه بعض دوائر
الغربيه لم تخفي فرحتها بهذا
التمرد والتقدم السريع من قوات فاجنر الى
حتى تخوم العاصمه الروسيه موسكو ثم
التراجع السريع هذا ربما ادى الى بعض
الارتباك في دوائر صنع القرار الغربيه
بحيث لم تعد تفهم ماذا يجري تحديدا هل هذا
فعلا صحيح او هل هذا التحليل يحمل شيء من
الوجاهه او المنطق
نعم صحيح لحد بعيد في البدايه كان هناك
اعتقاد بانه ما يحدث الان هو حاله تمرد
كما قلت قبل قليل اكبر تحدي يواجه بوتين
اكبر حتى من لحرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
وكانت هناك امال وطموحات ان يؤدي ذلك بشكل
او اخر الى اضعاف سلطته وبالتالي ربما
يطلق عليه في النظام رغم ان هناك فرق فرق
بين الحليفين الاوروبي والامريكي اوروبا
بشكل عام لا ترغب وليس لديها على الاقل
على راس سجدتها ما يتعلق بالاطاح ببطنه
بتغيير نظامه بل هناك من يخوف من يؤدي اي
صراع على السلطه الى الانتشار يطلق على
القاره الاوروبيه القاره الاوروبيه خاصه
فيما يتعلق بالدول الشرقيه
المحاذيه لروسيا لكن على جانب الاخر هناك
تقديرات امريكيه مختلفه تقول بانه الاطاحه
تمثل تغيير جذري او تغيير جدي في روسيا
عندما حدث وتراجع التمر بشكل اخر هناك
حاله ربما تخبط او حاله عدم ادراك لما
يحدث الان وبالتالي محاوله على الاقل كم
قلت قبل قليل لامرين الامر الاول عدم ظهور
بمظهر انهم يدعموا بشكل اخر فج حتى يتم
استخدامه من قبل بوتين والترويض باعتبارهم
ما حدث هو مؤامره غربيه لكن ايضا من جانب
اخر يتم استغلاله من اضعاف روح المعنويه
سواء لكره جنوده في اوكرانيا وبالتالي
ضعاف قطعه مع القتال ليس فقط ضد اوكرانيا
نعلم جميعا ان اوكرانيا مدعومه بشكل كبير
جدا سواء دعم عسكري او مالي او اقتصادي او
استخباراتي من الغرب خاصه من امريكا
وبالتالي اي اضعاف لروح المعنويه لجنود
الروس اي اضعاف للصوره الذهنيه الماخوذه
عن كتب اعتباره لرجل رجل قوي ومسيطر هي في
النهايه تصب في مصلحه اوكرانيا وبالتالي
مصلحه حلفاء الغرابيين وبالتالي حتى هذه
اللحظه على الاقل هناك حاله تفاوت او حاله
اختلاف في التقديرات الاوروبيه الامريكيه
فيما يتعلق بكيفيه التعاطي مع الوضع
الحالي في روسيا واوكرانيا ايضا
الدكتور خليل العلني استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه والعلوم السياسيه كان بعنا من
واشنطن شكرا جزيلا لك
في ردود الفعل الدوليه اجروا وزراء خارجيه
مجموعه السبع مشاورات بشان الوضع في روسيا
يتزمر ذلك مع قلق في بريطانيا من تداعيات
اي تغيير سياسي في روسيا جراء الازمه وفي
واشنطن قال البيت الابيض ان الرئيس جو
بايدن بحث هاتفيا الوضع في روسيا مع نظيره
الفرنسي والمستشار الالماني ورئيس الوزراء
البريطاني واضاف البيت ان القاده تاكدوا
دعمهم الثابته لاوكرانيا كما تحدث وزير
الدفاع الامريكي مع نظرائه في كندا وفرنسا
والمانيا وبولندا وبريطانيا لبحث الوضع في
روسيا وقالت وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه ان
اوستن سيبقي او سيبقى على اتصال مع
الحلفاء بشان الوضع في روسيا
وقد افاد مراسل الجزيره بان فريق الامن
القومي الامريكي اطلع الرئيس بايدن
ونائبته على اخر التطورات في روسيا ومن
بين المشاركين في اجتماع البيت الابيض
مستشار الامن القومي جيك سولفون ووزير
الخارجيه ووزير الدفاع لويد اوستن الى
جانب رئيس هيئه الاركان المشتركه ومديره
الاستخبارات القوميه ومدير وكاله
المخابرات المركزيه والممثله الامريكيه
الدائمه لدى الامم المتحده توماس
صرح مسؤولون اسرائيليون لموقع اكسيوس
الاخباريه الامريكي بالقول ان رئيس هيئه
الاركان الامريكيه الغى رحلته الى اسرائيل
التي كان من المقرر ان تبدا يوم الاحد
وانه سيبقى في واشنطن لمتابعه الاحداث
الجاريه في روسيا
هذا وتعتزم الولايات المتحده تاجيل فرض
عقوبات جديده على فاجنر الروسيه خشيه ان
تبدو وكانها تنحاز لاي طرف في روسيا
واضافت صحيفه
الامريكيه كانت تنوي الثلاثاء الاعلان عن
عقوبات جديده على القائمين على اعمال
التنقيب عن الذهب في افريقيا التابعين
لفاجنر بما في ذلك عمليات التنقيب في
جمهوريه في جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى
معنى من واشنطن المراسله الجزيره محمد
العلمي ومن برلين مراسل الجزيره محمد
البقالي نبدا مع محمد العلمي محمد بدا
اليوم
وانتهى سريعا بعد ما كانت هناك توقعات بان
تستمر هذه الازمه مده اطول وتاخذ ابعادا
اكثر خطوره لكن الاوضاع يبدو انه جرح
احتوائها بشكل كبير
ما الخطوه التاليه المتوقعه او كيف تابعت
الولايات المتحده ما جرى في روسيا وما
الخطوه التاليه المتوقعه من جانب الامريكي
لا تعرف الخطوه القادمه محمود لان بكل
بساطه الحكومه الامريكيه قررت انها لن
تتحدث ولن تعطي اي انطباع انها
بصدد ان تصبح طرفا فيما يحدث في روسيا
وعممت هذه التعليمات صارمه على جميع
السفرات امريكيه في العالم وايضا نص سقط
على ما يبدو بشان هذا الاتجاه
معظم حلفائها سواء خلال الاتصالات
المباشره لوزير الدفاع او لوزير الخارجيه
والغرض من ذلك على ما يبدو هو حرمان موسكو
او حتى مجموعه فاغنر من اي مبرر للوم
امريكا والغرب على ما يحدث في روسيا وترك
الامور تاخذ مجراها الطبيعي ويبدو ان
بدايه هذه الاحداث فاجات الامريكيين كما
فاجات كثيرين كما فاجات نهايتها
الامريكيين ايضا لكن
بعثرت الكثير من برامجهم خلال عطله نهايه
الاسبوع كما اشرت محمود وزير او رئيس هيئه
الاركان المشتركه الغى زياره له كان من
المرتقبه ان يقوم بها لاسرائيل والاردن
ايضا مستشار الامن القومي الغازيارا كانت
مقرره للدنمارك
وقرر اصطحاب الرئيس بيضا على غير العاده
الى منتجع في ضواحي واشنطن لاطلاعه خلال
بقيه عطله نهايه الاسبوع على مجريات
الاحداث في روسيا واضح من هذه البرامج
التي تغيرت ان واشنطن تبدي اهتماما بالغا
لما يجري في روسيا وهناك من يعتقد من
الخبراء على الاقل ان الدراما لم تنتهي
بعد في روسيا نهائيا الى ان تنجلي كل
تداعيات هذه الازمه
طبعا كانت الخشيه على مصير الاسلحه
النوويه وهذا ربما كان من دواعي الغاء
رئيس هيئه الاركان المشتركه لزيارته
المرتقبه للشرق الاوسط كانت هناك خشيه
ايضا من انتقال التوتر الى احدى الدول
المحاديه لروسيا من اعضاء الجدد لحل في
شمال الاطلسي مما كان قد سيعقد الوضع اكثر
لكن كما اشرت سابقا هناك نوع من الارتياح
الخجول صح التعبير ان ما حدث اضعف
الروسي وموقف الرئيس الروسي تحديدا فيما
يتعلق بالحرب الاوروبيه مع مراسل الجزيره
محمد البقالي هو معنا من برلين في المانيا
محمد طيله اليوم ايضا كانت هناك خلايا
ازمه داخل اروقه الاتحاد الاوروبي ومقر
النيتو ووزراء الخارجيه الاوروبيون لم
يتوقفوا عن التواصل بشان ما يجري داخل
روسيا اجمل لنا هذه المواقف وكيف تابع
الاحداث
بالفعل محمود كانت هناك حاله ترقب ومتابعه
دقيقه لما يحدث في روسيا ما يحدث هناك لا
ينظر اليه هنا اوروبيا باعتباره شانا خاصا
بروسيا بل ينظر اليه على انه لو تداعيات
كبيره على الحرب في اوكرانيا وايضا على
الوضع الامني الدولي وعلى المستوى
الاقليمي خاصه بالنسبه للدول القريبه من
روسيا لذلك كان هناك حراك دبلوماسي كبير
على مستوى الاوروبي واتصالات مكثفه من جهه
بغيه تقييم الوضع سياسيا وامنيا ومن ثم
بحث تاثيره على مسار الحرب في اوكرانيا
كانت هناك هذه محادثه الهاتفيه التي جمعت
الرئيس الامريكي مع الرئيس الفرنسي
والمستشاره الالماني ورئيس الوزراء
البريطاني كانت مكالمه جماعيه في هذه
المكالمه كذا متحدث باسم المستشاره
الالماني ان الزعماء الاربعه اتفقوا على
مواصله الدعم بشكل كامل لاوكرانيا مهما
طالما كان ذلك ضروريا وايضا البقاء خلال
الايام القلي كبيره على اتصال وثيق ايضا
مفوضه سياسات الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي اجرى مكالمه هاتفيه مع وزراء
خارجيه مجموعه السبعه لتبادل الراي بشان
هذا الوضع بل ان
المفوضه الاوروبي اطلق ما يسمى بمركز
الاستجابه للازمات وهو هذا المركز الذي
يطلق عندما تكون هناك ازمه في الافق
الرئيس الفرنسي ايضا تحدث مع الرئيس
البولندي مع الرئيس الامريكي مع المستشار
الالماني مع رئيس وزراء البريطاني وكان
النقاش يدور حول التاثير المحتمل لهذه
الاحداث الجاريه في روسيا على الحرب في
اوكرانيا وتاكيد الدعم المتواصل لاوكرانيا
كل هذه الاتصالات بالاضافه الى البيانات
الصادره عن معظم الدول الاوروبيه
تضمنت ثلاث نقاط رئيسيه من جهه التاكيد
على ان الاوروبيين يتابعون باهتمام ما
يحدث وهو اهتمام مفهوم ومن جهه ثانيه
تاكيد على الدعم المستمر لاوكرانيا
وهذا الامر قراناه في كل البيانات التي
صدرت وايضا دعوه الرعايه الاوروبيين الى
تجنب السفر الى روسيا هذا على المستوى
السياسي ايضا كانت هناك اتصالات على
المستوى العسكري لان وزير الدفاع الامريكي
ايضا تحدث مع نظرائه في فرنسا وفي المانيا
وكندا وبولندا والمملكه المتحده
بشكل عام يمكن ان نقول محمود ان
الاوروبيين لا يبدون لا يبدون انزعاجا مما
يحدث في روسيا من الحدث نفسه بل ربما
ينطبق عليهم في هذه القضيه المقوله
المشهوره لم امر بها ولم تساني ولكن
التحليلات السياسيه هنا في اوروبا ترى انه
ربما ما يحدث قد يشكل مناسبه او فرصه
لاضعافها الموقف الروسي عسكريا او معنويا
وهو سيكون مفيدا بالنسبه للموقف الاوروبي
وعلى مستوى الحرب في اوكرانيا ولكن ما
يمكن وصفه بالمخاوف او التوجس هو يتعلق من
جهه
ما يحدث على الحرب في اوكرانيا لانه لا
احد يعرف رد الفعل الروسي في حال تطورت
الموضوع ثم احتمالات
انفلات الموقف في روسيا وهذا الامر يبدو
ان هذا الاحتمال قد تراجع مع تراجع التوتر
شكرا جزيلا لك ومن قبل محمد العالمي شكرا
جزيلا لك محمد
العقد الاول من القرن العشرين وحتى اليوم
شهدت روسيا محطات مفصليه من الثوره عام
1917 مرورا بانهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي
ووصولا الى ما وصفه الرئيس الروسي فلادي
بتمرد قائد ميليشيا فاجنر يفغيني
في ذاكره السياسيه ترتبط صوره روسيا
بالقوه العسكريه
والتمدد الجيوسياسي الذي سيطر في ذروه
توسع الاتحاد السوفيتي ما بعد الحرب
العالميه الثانيه على غالبيه مساحات
اوروبا الشرقيه ووسط اسيا اما سطوته
السياسيه فوصلت الشرق الاوسط وافريقيا
وامريكا اللاتينيه فيما كان يسمى مره
المعسكر الشرقي وما وراء الستار الحديدي
الذي نسجته ضرورات السياسه ما بعد الحرب
العالميه الثانيه تقبع احداث شكلت او
ساهمت في تشكل المشهد الروسي وانهاء حقب
في تاريخ البلاد الحديث
اندلعت الحرب العالميه الاولى وروسيا
قيصريه يحكمها من سيصبح لاحقا قيصر سلاله
رومانوف الاخير نيكولاي تخلفت روسيا
القيصريه حينها عن ركب الثوره الصناعيه
الاوروبيه دخلت الحرب العالميه بازمه
اقتصاديه واجتماعيه عميقه رافقتها خسائر
كبيره على جبهات القتال بدات بذور ثوره
بالتشكل احتجاجات على نطاق واسع وتظاهرات
عماليه
فاضطر القيصر للتنازل عن العرش في مارس
عام
انشا مجلس الدوما حكومه مؤقته كانت اضعف
من ان تقف بوجه ما ستعرف لاحقا بالثوره
البرشفيه ففي اكتوبر من العام نفسه نجح
فصيل من حزب العمل الاشتراكي بقياده
فلاديمير بالاطاحه بالحكومه المؤقته وتشكي
الجمهوريه روسيا الاتحاديه الاشتراكيه وما
بين العامين
1917 و
1922 دخلت البلاد في حرب اهليه لتنتهي
بتشكل الاتحاد السوفيتي توسعت مساحته
بوعيد الحرب العالميه الثانيه واعتبر
حينها احد قطبي العالمي سياسيا استمرت
حياه الاتحاد السوفيتي حتى عام
انذاك شهدت البلاد تمردا هو الثاني منذ
الاطاحه بالقيصر بدا الرئيس السوفيتي
انذاك ميخائيل غورباتشوف ادخال اصلاحات
سياسيه فشكلت مجموعه من الحزب الشيوعي
المعارض لخطوات غورباتشوف لجنه طوارئ
وحاولت الاطاحه به
فاستقال غورباتشوف قررت انهاء عملك رئيس
للاتحاد السوفيتي والغى مكتب رئيس اتحاد
الجمهوريات السوفييتيه وسلم السلطه الى
الرئيس الروسي بوروسيا
اعتبر يلسن ما يجري بمثابه محاوله
انقلابيه فقمع التحرك بمساعده الجيش
وبلغ الامر قصف مقر مجلس الدومه وحل مجلس
السوفيت الاعلى منهيا بذلك العهد السوفيتي
مرت روسيا بعد انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي
بسنوات من التغيير السريع السياسيا
واجتماعيا
واقتصاديا عمل الرئيس الحالي فلاديمير
بوتين الذي تولى المنصب بعد يلسن على
اعاده بناء صوره روسيا دوله قويه بجيش قوي
واقتصاد قادر على المنافسه وفي خضم الحرب
على اوكرانيا يتحرك قائد ميليشيا فكنر
فيما وصفه الرئيس الروسي بنفسه بخيانه
ومحاوله تمرد
روسيا عانت من طعنه مماثله عام 1917 عندما
شاركت بلادنا في الحرب العالميه الاولى
ولكنه م سرقوا منها نصرها ليسجل ليفجين
بيجوشن انه قاد ثالث محاوله تمرد تشهدها
روسيا خلال قرن من الزمن
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد مستمرون مع حضراتكم في
متابعه التطورات داخل روسيا في اخر ملامح
المشهد اعلنا قائد مجموعه فاجنر قبوله
وساطه الرئيس البيلاروسي وامر قوته
بالعوده الى معسكراتها نشرت مواقع روسيه
صورا للحظه مغادره مالك شركه فاغنر ايفجين
مقر قياده المنطقه العسكريه الجنوبيه
بمدينه رستوف على الدون واكدت انترفيكس ان
قوات فاجنر مع جميع الياتها تغادر بشكل
كامل مقر قياده المنطقه العسكريه الجنوبيه
الذي سيطرت عليه صباح السبت
[موسيقى]
شركه فاغنر الروسيه قد اعلن ان قوته ستعود
الى معسكرتها بعد اقترابها من موسكو بمائه
كيلو متر مؤكدا ان القرار اتخذ حقنا
للدماء الروسيه واشار بريجوجل في تسجيل
صوتي الى ان قطره دم واحده لم تسفك خلال
ما سماه مسيره العداله وجاء ذلك بعد حديث
الرئيس البيلاروسي عن تقديم ضمانات امنيه
وساطه قادها معه
كانت هناك اراده لحل شركه فاجنر العسكريه
الخاصه خرجنا يوم 23 من يونيو في مسيره
العداله خلال يوم واحد قطعنا طريقا طويلا
ولم يعد يفصلنا عن موسكو سوى 200 كيلومتر
خلال هذا الوقت لم ترك فيها قطره دم واحده
من دماء مقاتلينا لكن حين لاحت لحظه يمكن
ان تراق فيها الدماء وادراكا منا
للمسؤوليه الكامله عن اراقه الدماء
الروسيه في صفوف اي من الطرفين قررنا
اعاده قوافلنا والمغادره في الاتجاه
المعاكس الى المعسكرات الميدانيه حسب
الخطه
هذا وقد اعلن المتحدث باسم الكريم
ان جهود الرئيس البيلاروسيه الكسندر
لوكاشينكو للوساطه كللت بالنجاح وحاله دون
اراقه الدماء كما انه سيتم اسقاط الدعوه
الجنائيه ضد بريجوجن وسيغادر الى
بيلاروسيا واضاف الكريم ان الضمانه في
تمكينه من المغادره وتعهد الرئيس بوتين
وانه لن يتم اتخاذه اجراءات قضائيه ضد
المقاتلين الذين شاركوا في التصعيد
العسكري ودخلوا الاراضي الروسيه وبالنسبه
لمقاتله فاغنر الذين رفضوا في البدايه
المشاركه في تصعيد
قال المتحدث باسم الكرملين ان جزءا منهم
سيوقعون عقودا مع وزاره الدفاع وقال
المتحدث الروسي انه لا علم له باي تغييرات
بشان ثقه الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين بوزير
الدفاع الروسي
ان تكون المفاوضات
تضمنت بحث اقاله مسؤولين في وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه
انضم الينا من موسكو مدير مكتب الجزيره
زاور شاوج منذ
ظهورنا قبل ساعه تقريبا من الانزور حدثت
ايضا تطورات اذ اشارت بعض وسائل الاعلام
الى ان مجموعه فاجنر غادرت بكامل عتادها
العسكري مقر القياده العسكريه الجنوبيه في
مدينه روستوف ماذا ايضا من تطورات
نعم بالفعل هذا ما اكدته عده مصادر
اعلاميه واكدته مصادرنا ايضا في مدينه
وعلى راسها
غادرت بالفعل مقر القياده قياده المنطقه
الجنوبيه الروسيه التي دخلتها صباح هذا
اليوم مغادرتها باتجاه المعسكرات التي
تمتلكها في عمق دونيسك
بحسب الاتفاق الذي اثمر
من خلال مفاوضات اجراها الرئيس البيلاروسي
مع مالك شركه
ولكن هذا الاتفاق ربما اوضحها تفاصيله
بشكل اكبر مع غياب التعليق لحد الان من
بريجوجن الذي عودنا في الفتره الاخيره على
تصريحات متواصله الان يبدو انه صامت
بانتظار الوصول ربما الى
مراكز تجمع قواته المتحدث باسم اوضح نقاط
اساسيه وهي انه من يرغب من قوات فارغنر
التي لم تشارك في هذا العصيان او في هذا
التمرد او في هذه العمليه التي جرت ابتداء
من الليله الماضيه يمكنها ان يوقع عقودا
مع وزاره الدفاع ويستمر في القتال الى
جانب وتحت قياده وزاره الدفاع هذا الموضوع
لا يشمل اولئك الذين شاركوا في التصعيد
الذي كما وصفه المتحدث ولكن لن يتم
ملاحقتهم قانونيا دون ان يوضح الى اين
سيذهبون واضح ان شركه فاقدر على الاقل هذا
ما تحاول
المراكز السياسيه والعسكريه عن ترسم صوره
لمستقبل
مؤسسه فاقدر او شركه في شكلها الحالي
ستنتهي بهذا الاتفاق بخروج
مديرها ومالكها وقائدها الى بيلاروسيا مع
رفع كل القضايا بحقه وايضا عدم ملاحقه
قضائيا كل من شارك في التمرد العسكري ولكن
دون الايضاح الينا سيذهب او لا اولئك هل
سيعودون الى الحياه الطبيعيه سيسلمون
سلاحهم سيذهبون الى افريقيا ولكن بدون شك
لن تسمح السلطات روسيا بان يكونوا ضمن
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
وضمن عداد القوات المسلحه نظرا لما توصفته
روسيا بالتمرد العسكري بشكل او باخر هنا
في موسكو ينظرون الى ما جرى بان هناك
تنازل نعم من قبل الرئيس الروسي باتجاه
التمرد العسكري والتعامل ربما الغير
القاسي معه
دمويًا وعسكريا
العفو بشكل او باخر عن القاده العسكريين
وعن اولئك الذين شاركوا في هذا الهجوم
وايضا توقيع الرئيس الروسي لقانونين بشكل
او باخر كان كان احد مطالب بريجوجن في
الاشهر الاخيره ولكن على الناحيه الاخرى
بوتين انقذ برايي الكثيرين البلاد من
مواجهه دمويه من حرب اهليه بين قوات
القوات الحرس الجمهوري وقوات وزاره الدفاع
مع قوه عسكريه مهمه كقوات
الحرب او الحمله العسكريه الروسيه على
اوكرانيا كانت في قلب خطاب السيد بريجوجن
وكذلك في قلب خطاب الرئيس بوتين
والمسؤولين الروس هل هناك اي مؤشرات على
تغيير في الخطه العسكريه الروسيه فيما
يتعلق باوكرانيا في الايام المقبله بعد
هذه التطورات المتلاحقه
بحسب المتحدث باسم لم تؤثر ولن تؤثر هذه
الاحداث التي شهدتها روسيا في ال24 ساعه
الماضيه على سير العمليه العسكريه هناك
طبعا العمليه العسكريه محمود منذ بدايتها
هناك تساؤلات كثيره حول اداء الجيش الروسي
حول اداره هذه العمليه العسكريه
يتحدث عن انه يريد ان يقوم بهدوء وبدون
الحاق خسائر بالقوات الروسيه بتحقيق اهداف
الاهداف التي وضعها امامها الكرملين من
اجل
تحقيق
ارادته روسيا من خلال هذه الحرب وبالتالي
لا يمكن القول الان ان هناك تغيير في
العمليه العسكريه او في خطه روسيا
الميدانيه بدرجه الاولى هناك التساؤلات
الكبرى متعلقه بمستقبل وزير الدفاع وقائد
الاركان الذي هاتين الشخصيتين اللتين
اختفت تماما عن المشهد في هذا اليوم وهيا
براي كثيرين هنا على الاقل بحسم ما
تتناوله المواقع الاخباريه والمحللين
السياسيين هي هو تصرف غير لائق بقياده او
بقاده هرم السلطه العسكريه في روسيا هناك
من يتوقع انه في الساعات او ربما الايام
القادمه سيقوم بوتين بتغيير القياده
العسكريه وربما لن يذهب الى ذلك ولكن
الامر ياتي في اطار التكهنات والتحليلات
عاده
القياده الروسيه تعودت ان ان لا تقوم
بتغييرات
حاسمه في هرم السلطه العسكريه خلال الحروب
وبالتالي ربما
تبقى الامور على حالها مع تغييرات طفيفه
في ما يتعلق بالعمليه العسكريه
شكرا جزيلا لك
من اوكرانيا الى داخل روسيا تلاحقت
التطورات خلال الساعات 24 الماضيه بتفجر
الخلاف بين مجموعه فاجنر ووزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ووصوله الى نقطه الصدام في
التقرير التالي استعراض لمسار الاحداث
ورصد لخارطه تحرك مقاتلي فاجنر وصولا الى
ما افضت اليه من حاله استنفار قصوى في
موسكو ثم اعلان عوده القوات الى قواعدها
ما بين السوليدار وباخموت ظلت قوات فاجنر
راس الحربه في الحرب التي تشنها روسيا على
اوكرانيا بينما يتقدم الجيش الروسي في
جبهتي خرسون جنوبا وخار كيف شرقا تصاعد
الخلاف بين قياده فاجنر ووزاره الدفاع
وبلغ مرحله وجه فيها قائد فاجنر اتهامات
مدويه للقياده العسكريه قائلا انها كانت
تضلل بوتين بتقارير لا تعكس ما يجري في
اوكرانيا وان الاوليجارشيا هي من حرضت على
الحرب بلغ الخلاف ذروته عندما اتهم
بريغوجين وزير الدفاع بتوجيه اوامر لقصف
قواته في احد معسكراتها في اوكرانيا ما
لبثت ان تحولت انتقادات الى تهديد ثم الى
تمثيل
امر قوته بالتحرك من اوكرانيا الى داخل
روسيا فيما سماها المسيره من اجل العداله
ضد مسؤوليه دفاع
عبرت الحدود وتوغلت من مناطق جنوب روسيا
كانت الوجهه الاولى مدينه روستوف حيث يوجد
مقر قياده الروسيه للعمليه العسكريه في
اوكرانيا ومن مطارها تقلع الطائرات
الروسيه لتنفيذ عملياتها دخلها مقاتلوا
فاجنان واعلنوا سيطرتهم على منشاتها
العسكريه وعلى المطار دون اطلاق رصاصه
واحده وهدد بريجين بالزحف الى موسكو ما لم
ياتي وزير الدفاع سيرجي شويجو لمقابلته في
روستوف
تحقق الوعيد عندما تقدمت ارتال عسكريه
لقوات فاجنر باقصى سرعه على طول الطريق
السريع بين روستوف وموسكو حسب موقع ريبار
العسكري في مقاطعه فيرونيش ذكر قائد فاجنر
ان طائرات مروحيه للجيش الروسي قصفت قافله
عسكريه من قواته كانت تسير على طريق ام
اربعه باتجاه موسكو هنا في مدينه فرونيش
استولى مقاتل فاجنر على منشات عسكريه وبات
طريقهم نحو العاصمه موسكو معبده حاله
الاستنفار في موسكو ظهرت في التحصينات
العسكريه التي اقامها الجيش والحواجز التي
نصبها على احد مداخل المدينه واغلقت
الحدائق العامه الى اشعار اخر
وبينما قال الرئيس الشيشاني رمضان قادروف
ان القوات الشيشانيه انطلقت باتجاه مناطق
التوتر في روستو لدعم الجيش الروسي اعلن
ما يسمى فيلق المتطوعين الروس المعارض ان
قواته موجوده داخل روسيا ومستعده لمساعده
فاجنر في القضاء على نظام بوتين بعد ساعات
اعلنت الرئاسه البيلاروسيه ان محادثات بين
الرئيس الكسندر لوكاشينكو وقائد فاجنر
افضت الى موافقه على وقف تقدم قواته مقابل
ضمانات امنيه ثم اعلن اعاده قواته الى
قواعدها بعدما صارت على بعد 200 كيلومتر
من موسكو
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من موسكو العقيد فيكتور محرر
الشؤون العسكريه في وكاله تاس الروسيه سيد
لتوفكن هل لديك تفسير لهذا التوغل السريع
لقوات فاجنر داخل الاراضي الروسيه حتى
تخوم العاصمه موسكو على بعد 200 كيلومتر
فقط دون ان يطلق عليها طلقه واحده
باستثناء ما ذكرته وسائل الام روسيه
واحتفت به كثيرا واظهرت كثيرا من قصف
لمدرعه او مركبه تابعه لقوات فاجنر في
مدينه فارونج رغم انها كانت على طريق
مفتوح تماما والقوات المسلحه الروسيه تلقت
امرا صريحا من الرئيس بوتين بسحق هذا
التمرد والتصدي له كيف تفسر هذا
لم يصلوا الى موسكو
وصلوا الى فرونج وهذا بعيدا بعيد عن موسكو
هذا الشيء الاول الشيء الثاني لم يكون
هناك اي مهمه ان يقوموا بالهجوم على هذه
القافله لانهم جنود حاربوا ببطوله على
خطوط التماس مع اوكرانيا
وحرروا
الكثير من المناطق ولذلك الحديث كان عن
الحفاظ على ارواحهم والحفاظ على هؤلاء
الجنود
المهم كان ان نتحدث معهم حتى يفهموا
اخطائهم خاصه ان من توجه لموسكو كان قد
خدعوا وقيل لهم انهم سوف يذهب الى بيل جرد
للدفاع عن بالقرد من العصابات الاوكرانيه
والشيء الثالث السبب الثالث ان ما من احد
كان يريد ان يبدا بحرب على الاراضي
الروسيه ان
الهجمات ضد هذه العربات التي كانوا يسيرون
هذا يعني
البدء بعمليات عسكريه
والركاب في السيارات هم جنود محترفين
عندها كانت ستبدا حرب داخل روسيا كانت
ستضرر ايضا على المقاطعه السيد سيد لطوفكن
عذرا على المقاطعه حينما تقول انهم لم
يدخلوا موسكو يمكن الرد بانهم ساروا مسافه
800 كيلو متر على طريق مفتوح وام اربعه
الطريق السريعه المفتوح الذي يخلو من
العوائق وساروا بمدرعات امام اعين كل
القوات المسلحه الروسيه من رستوف وحتى
فارونج دون ان تطلق عليهم او دون ان يعرقل
تقدمهم اي قوات من المؤسسه العسكريه وذلك
بعد ان تلقت يعني هناك هناك كلام صريح من
الرئيس بلادي بانه الخونه سيدفعون الثمن
وهذا التمرد سيتم سحقه هو التصدي له
وسيلاحق المجرمون قضائيا والى اخره يعني
هذا هذا شيء طبيعي في تقديرك
ان هذا شيء طبيعي ولكن حكمه
الاداره تقع في حل النزاع دون اي سكب
للدماء وهذا ما قام به بوتين مع لوكاشينكا
اليس هذا شيئا جيدا هل هذا شيء سيء ان
يحلوا كل المسائل بين مسائل الاشخاص الذين
خدعوا وضللوا كانوا عادوا
لمعسكراتهم للاستمرار في المعارك ضد
اوكرانيا
ما الضروره في قتلهم ولماذا نقوم
باعتقالهم وحبسهم لانهم ضروريين لروسيا
يعني هذه العمليه لها طرفان انت تفسر طرف
او تفسر سلوك الطرف الخاص بالرئيس
فلاديمير بوتين والمؤسسه العسكريه الروسيه
لكن الطرف الاخر
علل كثيرا او رفع كثيرا من سقف تصريحاته
وقال ان هناك يعني شكك في نوايا الحمراء
العسكريه الروسيه على اوكرانيا وقال ان
وزير الدفاع شيجوس سيعدم داخل او في موسكو
وسيتم محاسبه من وصفهم بالخونه والمتامرين
وما الى ذلك كيف تراجع الرجل بكل هذه
السهوله عن هذا السقف العالي وقبل فقط
بالانسحاب والضمرات الامنيه والنفي او
اللجوء الى بيلاروسيا بهذه الصوره
ان هذا جدل وهذا حديث الذي يستخدمه السيد
بريجوجل نعلم انه يتحدث كثيرا بطرق عاطفيه
في روسيا لا نقتل على الكلام ولا نقتل على
الجدل نحن نعاقب على الاعمال الغير
القانونيه المساله كانت
في حل الاوضاع وحلتها دون شفق للدماء ودون
ضرر القوات الروسيه
والاشخاص الذين يخدمون في قوات فاغنر او
يعملون هناك
هذه هذه الاوضاع حلحلت ولا اعلم اسباب
انزعاج البعض من
الحفاظ على الدماء في روسيا وكان بعض يريد
ان تقوم روسيا بحرب اهليه داخليه
[موسيقى]
كما وصفه الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين هل تعتقد
ان هذا جزاء مكافئ ومعقول لمن احدث تمردا
يعد او في الظاهر هو الاخطر في تاريخ
روسيا الحديث واكبر ازمه يتعرض لها الرئيس
طيله سنوات حكمه التي تزيد عن 20 عاما
لقد اذيحت التهديدات
والاخطار ولم يحدث حرب اهليه وفما السيء
في هذا هذا لم اقل سيء وحسن عفوا عفوا
انا اقول ان هذا قد يفتح الباب لتمردات
اخرى من قبل فصائل او من لا يرضون عن اداء
الرئيس بلاديمير بوتين داخل المؤسسه
العسكريه يعني الم يكن من الاولى ان تكون
او ان ينزل جزاء راضع بمن اقاموا وقادوا
هذا التمرد حتى لا يغري اخرين بان يحذوا
حذواهم
انا اعتقد
ان السلطه في روسيا سوف تتعامل مع هذه
الاوضاع بعقلانيه انظروا الى الشيشان كان
هناك حرب
استمرت عشر سنوات اليوم
الشيشان جمهوريه مزدهره تحت ظل روسيا
الشيشان التي كنا نلقي عليهم اسماء
الارهابيين والعصابات الان تخدم روسيا وهم
يحاربون لاجل مصلحه روسيا
فهل يجب علينا ان نستمر بملاحقتهم بما وقع
قبل عشر سنوات بما فيه الرئيس
الشيشاني هذه هذا موقف عجيب من بعض
الاشخاص نحن نقوم بحلحله الاوضاع بطرق
سلميه عندما نستطيع ولكن اذا كنا لا
نستطيع ان نستخدم الاسلحه ولكن يجب ان
نبدا بالوسائل
السلميه لحل الاوضاع وكوننا قمنا بهذا
بطريقه سلميه واوقفنا التهديدات التي كانت
قد تؤدي لحرب اهليه في روسيا اعتقد ان هذا
لا يرضي البعض ولكننا راضين تماما
والاداره راضيه والمواطنين ايضا معجبين
فيها هذا يعني اوجه الشبه بينما كان يحدث
في الشيشان وبين تمرد جماعه ربما بعيد
كثيرا عن بعضهم البعض لكن في كل الاحوال
شكرا جزيلا لك العقيد فيكتور لتوفكن محرر
الشؤون العسكريه في وكاله تيتاس الروسيه
كيف وصل الوضع الى ما وصل اليه لينفرط عقد
عقد العلاقه بين روسيا الرسميه ومجموعه
فاجنر من التاسيس الى الانتشار ولعب
بادوار في ساحات مختلفه تتقدمها اوكرانيا
لم تخلو العلاقه من توترات وخلافات وتراشق
بين ملك فاجنر ايفيني ووزير الدفاع
الشانجو ورئيس الاركان تكرر ذلك في محطات
مختلفه ابرزها في بخموت في ظل اتهامات
بغياب الامداد بالذخيره والدعم اللوجستي
بل وباستهداف المجموعه من التاسيس الى
المواجهه مع الكريم في هذا التقرير لعبد
القادر عراضه
مجموعه فاغنر يعتقد ان مؤسسها الفعلي
ديمتري اوتكين القائد السابق للقوات
الخاصه في المخابرات العسكريه الروسيه
واختار لها اسم فاجنر تيمنا بالموسيقار
الالماني الشهير المفضل لادولف هتلر توصف
بانها شركه امنيه عسكريه خاصه
وتصنفها تقارير استخباراتيه بمجموعه روسيه
عسكريه شبه رسميه تتمتع بالاستقلاليه
وتتبع بشكل غير مباشر وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه لاحقا اصبحت فاجنر مملوكه لرجل
الاعمال
ويعرف باسم الطباخ بوتين لادارته شركه
كونكورد المنظمه لحفلات الاستقبال
بالكرملين وهو سجين جنائي سابق ابان حقبه
الاتحاد السوفيتي بدات مجموعه تظهر على
المشهد في روسيا عام 2014 بعد ضم روسيا
شبه جزيره القرم وتتنوع القدرات القتاليه
لعناصرها كما نفذتها هجمات في شرق
اوكرانيا
بقيت مجموعه عسكريه خاصه غير موجوده على
الورق بصوره رسميه لتسهيل التخلص من اي
جرائم او انتهاكات تقدم عليها بحسب مركز
الدراسات الاستراتيجيه الدوليه الا انها
افتتحت رسميا اول مقر لها في مدينه سانتيت
الروسيه في نوفمبر من العام الماضي وقال
بريغوجين ان مهمه مركز فاجنر الرئيسي
توفير بيئه مريحه لتوليد افكار جديده
لتحسين القدره الدفاعيه لروسيا لم يخفي
ذلك اتهامات بارسال مسلحيها الى دول عربيه
واخرى في امريكا اللاتينيه وافريقيا
وتنفيذ ما توصف بالعمليه القادره في مناطق
النزاعات المختلفه
سجلت نشاطات لفاجنر في سوريا لدعم قوات
النظام السوري منذ 2016 خصوصا في حقول
النفط في دير الزور وتدمر وفي ليبيا لدعم
قوات اللواء المتقاعد خليفه حفتر كما
انتشرت في جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى وفي
السودان منذ 2017 تحت غطاء شركات التنقيب
عن الذهب وفي مدغشقر وموزمبيق واخر انتشار
لها في مالي بعد انسحاب القوات الفرنسيه
من هناك
وخلال حرب اوكرانيا تضخم عدد مقاتل فاغنر
وكشف في رسالته الهجوميه على وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه عن وجود خمسه وعشرين الفا من
قواته في روسيا فضلا عن المقاتلين على
الجبهات في اوكرانيا ولم يكن تفجر الصدام
بين مؤسسي فاغنر ايفوجن والمؤسسه الرسميه
الروسيه مفاجئا اذ ان مؤشرات الصراع
تزايدت منذ العام الماضي وقد شكلت المعركه
على السوليدار الاوكرانيه التي انتهت مطلع
يناير كانون الثاني الماضي بسيطره القوات
الروسيه عليها مؤشرا على حجم الخلافات قبل
ان تبدا شكاوي المجموعه بعدم تزويدها
بالسلاح وامدادات الذخيره الكافيه مع
تهديد بالانسحاب من بخموت
وزير الدفاع ورئيس الاركان بمحاوله تدمير
المجموعه واعاقه وصول المتطوعين وقال ان
روسيا قد تواجه ثوره مماثله لثوره عام 17
وتخسر الحرب في اوكرانيا
وفيما بدا خطوه لتقليص نفوذ المجموعه جاء
قرار وزير الدفاع الروسي بالزام جميع
تشكيلات المتطوعين الروس بتوقيع عقد مع
وزاره الدفاع حتى الاول من يوليو تموز رد
بريغوجين لم يتاخر برفض التوقيع بل واردف
اياما بعدها بالقول ان القوات الروسيه
تتراجع في شرق اوكرانيا وجنوبها خلافا
لتصريحه بوتين اتهم بريغوجين القياده
العسكريه الروسيه بقتل عدد كبير من عناصره
في قصف استهدافهم وتعهد بالرد والانتقام
وطلب بمحاسبه كل من وزير الدفاع ورئيس
الاركان وحرك قواته وصف بوتين ذلك بالتمرد
المسلح واعتبره خيانه لروسيا وطعنه في
الظهر
ورد بريفوجين بالقول ان مقاتليه وطنيون لن
يستسلموا وان بوتين كان مخطئا للغايه
عندما وصفهم بالخونه
وبينما فتح جهاز الامن الفيدرالي تحقيقا
بتهمه الدعوه الى تمرد المسلح قالت اللجنه
الوطنيه لمكافحه الارهاب في روسيا ان قائد
فاجنر يواجه عقوبه بالسجن لمده تصل الى 20
عاما
وفي ردود الفعل من كييف تحدثت القوات
الاوكرانيه عن تمكنها من اختراق تحصينات
روسيه في شرق البلاد والتقدم على جبهات
بخموت اما الرئيس الاوكراني
كانت له تصريحات عديده على مدار اليوم
تفاعل فيها مع الاحداث في روسيا زيلينسكي
قال ان تمرد عناصر مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه
كشف عن فوضى كامله في روسيا واضاف ان
بلاده لم تصمت ولن تقف مكتوفه الايدي كما
انها قادره على حمايه اوروبا من الشر
والفوضى الروسيه بحسب تعبيره
اليوم هو يوم لا ينبغي ان يكون فيه صمت
بالتاكيد ونحن بالتاكيد بحاجه الى قياده
راى العالم اليوم ان ساده روسيا لا
يسيطرون على اي شيء لا شيء على الاطلاق
ببساطه فوضى كامله والافتقار الى اي
امكانيه للتنبؤ
تثير التطورات في روسيا اهتمام دول الجوار
حيث دعت جورجيا الى بحث وضع منطقه افخاذيه
واوسيتيا الانفصاليتين وذكرت وزاره
الداخليه البيلاروسيه انها تتابع عن كثب
الاوضاع في روسيا وان قواتها تنفذ خدمتها
بالتوافق مع سير الاحداث من جانبه قال
مكتب الرئيس الكازاخستاني قاسم عند الرئيس
عقد اجتماعا لمناقشه المخاطر التي تواجه
بلاده بسبب الوضع في روسيا
يوم عصيب على روسيا كان بطل احداثه في
جيني بريكوجن قائد ومالك قوات شركه فاجنر
وذلك بعد اعلانه التمرد على الجيش الروسي
واعتزامه الزحف او اعتزامه الزحف الى
روسيا فبعد ساعه عصيبه بدا فيها الا مخرج
من المواجهه وحسم التمرد بحسب تاكيدات
الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين قرر بريغوجين
التراجع عن مخططه ووقف التقدم الى روسيا
ضمن قائد فاجنر سلامته وسلامه جنوده
واسقاط الجرم عنه لكن روسيا ستلاحقها ازمه
الاداء العسكري في حرب تاخذ كل يوم شكلا
من اشكال الاستنزاف وكانها تعيد سيره حرب
اخرى خاضتها موسكو في افغانستان انتهت قصه
فاجنر وبقيت عبرتها لروسيا ولغيرها تقرير
فوزي بشرى
انها البنادق غير المؤتمنه تعيش في كنف
الجيوش الرسميه حين من الزمن ثم ما اسرع
ما تتوجه فوهاتها الى صدور من صنعها روسيا
اليوم في هول من مشهد استداره بنادق فاجنر
الى القوات المسلحه الروسيه في لحظه من
اكثر ازمنه روسيا بوتين حرجا وانفتاحا على
سيناريوهات تتصل باسئله وجوديه قاسيه
روسيا المنخرطه في حرب في اوكرانيا تقول
انها تخوضها في الواقع ضد حلف الناتو
المتورط فيها تمويلا وتسليحا ودعما فنيا
في خضم هذه الحرب التي تشهد تقدم للقوات
الاوكرانيه في هجوم واسع مكنها من استعاده
بعض ما فقدت من اراضي في هذا الوقت الحالي
من سير المعركه يقرر مالك شركه باجنر يبكي
بريكويين سحب قواته ومغادره ارض المعركه
الى داخل روسيا تدخل قواته مدينه روستوف
في الجنوب الروسي وتقول انها استولت على
المقر العسكريه وانها في طريقها الى موسكو
الماساه في هذه الدراما الروسيه هي ان
زعيم باقنر
هو من عول عليه بوتين في تغيير معادله
الحرب برجاله البالغ عددهم 25 الف مقاتل
قبل رجال فاجنر في الحرب ورجال فاجنر كما
يصفهم الاعلام الروسي اليوم ليسوا سوى
مجرمين سابقين ومغامرين يدخلون الحرب من
اجل الكسب كما يدخلون ناديا للقمار حيث
الربح والخساره
يتارجحان يتارجح الموت والحياه في الحرب
ولان المال والعتاد والذخائر هي شرط
البنادق المستاجره فقد خرج بريكوجين يصب
قياده الجيش الروسي ممثلا في كبار القاده
ابتداء من وزير الدفاع
ورئيس هيئه
الاركانوف محملا اياهم الاداء البائسه
للقوات الروسيه الحرب ثم هدد رئيس فاجنر
بالانسحاب من جبهه القتال متهما وزير
الدفاع بانه امر الجيش بفتح النار على
جنوده ثم بدا لرئيس باجنر ان اخراج روسيا
الى بر الامان لا يكون الا بتجريده عسكريه
والتحرك الى موسكو بالغا ما بلغت قوه
فاجنر سيكون عملا انتحاريا الا اذا كان
تحركا ضابنا لاسناد كبير من قاده الجيش
وهذا سيناريو اذا حدث فسيحيل الى شيء واحد
والانقلاب على بوتين فهل تمت تواطؤ بين
قطاع من الجيش مع فاجنر وهل يقبل المزاج
العام في روسيا صعود هذه المجموعه الى سده
الحكم في موسكو ايا ما بلغ الضيق بسياسات
بوتين في الحرب وغير الحرب هل يملك زعيم
فاقمر مناصرين في الطبقه السياسيه في
الكريملين وخارجه وهل حديث يفقيني عن ثوره
شعبيه كبرى في روسيا بسبب الحرب هو ضرب من
التحريض وحمل الناس على الاعتقاد بالحاجه
الى هذه الثوره هكذا فكر بريكوجين ثم عاد
فراجع حساباته فاثر السلامه في لعبه للقوه
بدت الخسائر فيها اوضح من المكاسب فقال
انه امر جنوده بالعوده من الزحف الى موسكو
وكان بوتين الماخوذ بتمرد قائد عليه وصف
الامر بانه طعنه في الظهر لروسيا وان
سلوكين يمثل خيانه للبلاد وان التعامل معه
سيكون قاسيا وحاسما فليس من هدن هنا ولا
من مستطاع لا خير في كثير من نجواهم يوم
ثقيل على روسيا واثقل منهما سياتي بعده في
بلد يخوض حربا ضد اوكرانيا التي تقف من
خلفها امم من خلفها امم وتحارب في الان
نفسه عدوا من بني جلدتها كانت تظنه حتى
امس حمايتها ودعمها السريع ساعه فزعه
درس اخر في عدم الركون الى التنظيمات
العسكريه غير الرسميه فوالاها دائما
لبنادقها المتخففه من ثقل الافكار والقيم
فاجمل صيت واسع من التدخلات غير الحميده
في العالم لا سيما في افريقيا حيث تبيع
البنادق وتبيع معها الايادي القاتله كذلك
مثل ما حدث في ليبيا وافريقيا الوسطى
والسودان وغيرها من البلدان بتكلفه عاليه
ستحاول روسيا القضاء على فاجنر التي بدا
فعلها في ظل الحرب الدائره وكانه محاوله
تفجير للقلعه الروسيه من الداخل
اوكرانيا والغرب جميعهم يتابعون ما يحدث
في روسيا وفي موسكو تحديدا فرئيس فاجنر
بريكو جين الملقب بطباخ بوتين يقدم طبقه
الاخير لصديقه الرئيس بوتين منهيا مقوله
الخبز
والملح
ينضم الينا من العاصمه الاوكرانيه
رئيس وزير مساعد وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
السابق سيد مرحبا بك
طيله اليوم الماضي او الساعات الاربعه
والعشرين الماضيه لم يكف الرئيس الاوكراني
فلو ديميرز الينسكي عن اطلاق التصريحات
وبدا وكانه مبتهج كثيرا بما يجري داخل
روسيا هل تعتقد ان نهايه اليوم لم تاتي
على مكانها
الحقيقه ان من المستحيل ان
يتكانه كان من الممكن ان احد كيف سوف
تنتهي هذه الاعمال من قبل السيد بريغوجين
ولكن في جميع الحالات بغض النظر عن
نهايه هذه الاحداث بالنسبه لاوكرانيا هذا
مؤشر ممتاز جدا لان هذا يؤكد ان السلطه
المركزيه في روسيا
لديها مشاكل كبيره بالنسبه
للسيطره على اراضيها والتشكيلات العسكريه
التي تم انشاؤها ولذلك اعتقد ان اوكرانيا
لم
يخيب ظنهم بنهايه هذه الاحداث خاصه ان
النهايه لم تاتي بعد النهايه قادمه يعني
كيف تقول هذا
يعني في التحليل الاخير اعطى الازمات التي
واجهت بوتين لم تاخذ منه اكثر من 24 ساعه
حتى يتغلب عليها
انا اعتقد ان اهم شيء هنا
اهم ما ظهر في هذه الاحداث انهم زعزعوا
سمعه بوتين وهذه ضربه مهمه جدا لان بوتين
طوالي 23 سنه حاول ان يشكل صوره عن شخص
يسيطر على كل شيء في دولته واليوم نرى ان
الشركات العسكريه الخاصه التي كانت لدرجه
كبيره
محايده او مناصره
لبوتين الان خرجت عليه ربما لم ينقلبوا
على بوتين ولكن هذه الاعمال ضد بوتين وهذه
ليست الحاله الاولى لان هناك
عمليات عسكريه في
برديانس وبوتين لا يستطيع ان يقوم باي شيء
ضد هذه الاحداث لذلك الاوضاع المتزعزعه
والتي تجمع ت في الداخل الروسي هي في
تزايد وتصاعد وهذا يضر في سمعته امام
القوات العسكريه خاصه كيف يمكن ان تترجم
اوكرانيا هذه الازمه الى منافع فيما يتعلق
بالحرب الدائره على ارضها من قبل القوات
الروسيه
انا اعتقد ان اوكرانيا لديها امكانيات
محدوده
للتاثير على هذا النداع الداخلي لروسيا
من الممكن ان يقوموا بعمليات
اعلاميه نفسيه للضغط على روسيا ولكن في
ارض المعركه
من الصعب ان تؤدي العمليات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه بالتاثير على الداخل الروسي
ولكن قد تزيد الاوضاع صعوبه وخاصه على
خطوط التما وكل هذه المشاكل التي تجمعت
لاشهر قد
تتحول الى كارثه في النهايه وقد يحدث هذا
على شكل مفاجئ تماما كما فاجاتنا هذه
الاحداث التي قام بها السيد الوصف المجربه
في كثير من الازمات هو
التصدير الازمه نحو الخارج او محاوله
البحث عن حلول او مهرب من الازمه الداخليه
في سوره المغامرات العسكريه الخارجيه اذا
طبقنا ذلك على الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
هل تتخوفون من تط الهجوم الروسيه خلال
الفتره المقبله في محاوله لترميم الصوره
العسكريه لروسيا
هذا سؤال ممتاز جدا
بالفعل هذه تهدات موجوده لان هذا تصرف
كلاسيكي عندما تتعرض روسيا لازمات تحاول
ان تحول انتباه الجمهور لاحداث اخرى
وللاسف في هذه الحاله اوكرانيا هي
في قمه القائمه التي سوف تستخدمها روسيا
للقيام بهذا قد لا تكون هذه
ضربات موجعه
لاوكرانيا قد تكون بعض الحملات
اعتقد ان هذا سوف ينعكس اكثر على المساحه
الاعلاميه الروسيه وهذا ليس مفاجئ لنا
لان حملات الانتقام هي مستمره وهي احد
عناصر سياسه الكرملين
التي تستخدمها طوالي السنوات الاخيره ضد
اوكرانيا شكرا جزيلا لك
مساعد وزير الدفاع الاوكراني السابق كان
معنا من العاصمه الاوكرانيه
من موسكو اندريه فيدروف نائب وزير
الخارجيه الروسي السابق سيد مرحبا بك بعد
ذهاب
قائد مجموعه فاغنر الى بيلا روسيا ما هو
المصير الذي ينتظره هل تطوى بذلك صفحه هذه
الشخصيه من العسكريه والحياه السياسيه
الروسيه
[موسيقى]
في هذه المرحله هذا حل مؤقت
لان الوضع برمته لم ينتهي بعد المشكله هي
انه يجب ان يكون هناك جوله اخرى من
المفاوضات حول وضع مجموعه فاكنر
باسره لان ما سبب او حفز هذا الوضع كان
قرار وزير الدفاع منذ اسبوعين
بان تكون كافه مجموعات العسكريه غير
الرسميه بما فيها يجب ان تلغى اعتبار من
الاول من شهر يوليو تموز وهذا مشكله كبيره
لفاكن لانه في هذه الحاله سوف تكون مجموعه
جزء من الجيش لا اكثر ولا اقل ايضا ما
مصير قوات فاجنر التي شاركت والتي لم
تشارك يعني هناك حديث عن انخراط وتوقيع
عقود مع اولئك الذين لم يشاركوا في التمرد
اما الذين شاركوا فقد صدر عنهم عفوا الى
اين سيذهبون هل يعودون الى روسيا الى اين
يذهبون تحديدا
هذا سؤال
اساسي مطروح لانه رسميا
ليس هناك اي مسوغات قانونيه
تبرر وجود شركات الامن الخاص هذه احد
المسارات المحتمله هو ان ينضم جزء من
المجموعه الى الجيش والباقون يستمرون
بالعمل مع
في افريقيا في مالي في افريقيا الوسطى الى
ما هنالك ايضا هل تنتظر السيد افقيني
اي ادوار اخرى ام هذه هي المهمه الاخيره
او هذا هذه المغامره الاخيره قبل التقاعد
في تقديرك هل هل ستكون له انشطه اخرى
مكتفه بايصال الرساله التي كان يريد
ايصالها
المشكله هي في ان
بريكوتينر يتمتعاني بشعبيه كبيره لدى شعب
الروسي
وهذا امر لا يمكن تجاهله بكل بساطه اذا
يمكنه ان يؤثر على الوضع الداخلي
وفي هذه المرحله
هذا امر حساس لا سيما مع استمرار العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه بتقديرك ما اثر كل ما حدث
او احداث الساعات الاربعه والعشرين
الماضيه على العمليات العسكريه الروسيه في
اوكرانيا
لا اعتقد انه سوف يؤثر على العمليه
العسكريه بحد ذاتها ولكن قد يؤثر على
المزاج على معنويات الجيش الموجود هناك
لان الكثير من هؤلاء الجنود كانوا يقاتلون
جنبا الى جنب مع قوه فاجنر وبالتالي هذا
قد لا يكون افضل مؤشر الى كيفيه تبلور
الامور وطبعا
السؤال المطروح هو ما يجب القيام به من
الان فصاعدا لانفاك طلعت بدور اساسي في
تحرير بخموت
في عمليات خطيره وحساسه جدا على الجبهات
سؤالي قبل ساعه تقريبا من الان كان معنا
خبير عسكري تحدث عن ان القوات الروسيه
النظاميه
قابلت بعض لحظات ومحطات التعثر داخل
اوكرانيا ولذلك استعانت بقوات فاجنر التي
بدا انها على مستوى عالي من التدريب
وقادره على اداء مهماتها بكفاءه اذا
اخرجنا هذه القوات من معادله الحرب
الروسيه في اوكرانيا كيف تتوقع ان يؤثر
ذلك على اداء تلك القوات
قد يكون في ذلك مشكله لان فاكنير كانت
الاكثر خبره
وتشربه في المعارك داخل المدن وليس على
سبيل الصدفه انه في بخموت
مئه في المئه من العمليات العسكريه كانت
بفضل فاجنر
للجيش الروسي ليس هناك وحدات مماثله قادر
على القيام بالعمليات العسكريه داخل المدن
وهو الجزء الاصعب بالنسبه الى العمليات
العسكريه في اوكرانيا الهدف الذي اعلنه من
هذه الخطوه المفاجئه كان
يعني تصحيح المسار ومسيره العداله التي
قال انه يقوم بها وليس وليس انقلابا على
القياده السياسيه في روسيا هل تعتقد انه
بعد ان وصلت هذه الرساله بقوه يمكن ان
يقدم الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين على تنفيذ او
اتخذت بعض القرارات الحاسمه الراديكاليه
داخل المؤسسه العسكريه الروسيه لتصحيح
ادائها
اعتقد انه بعد كل ما حصل سوف يكون هناك
حاجه على الاقل الى
توضيح الصوره
التعامل مع شركات الامن الخاص
وعلى الارجاح سوف تتخذ قرارات بشان الوضع
داخل الجيش الامر خطير وجدي الان لان
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه في اوكرانيا تجري
على قدم وساق
وتبقى مشاكل تواجه الجيش الروسي وزير
الدفاع ورئيس هيئه الاركان كان على راس
الشخصيات التي اتهمها
بالخيانه وسوء الاداء ويعني اطلق حتى
اوصاف غير لائقه اخلاقيا عليهما هل تعتقد
ان التغيير
يستهدف هذين الشخصين اقصد ان الرئيس
فلاديمير بوتين سيقرر مصيرهما في الايام
القليله القادمه
لا اعتقد ان بوتين سوف يتخذ قرارات بشان
هذين الشخصين لكن من الواضح
ان هناك بعض التغييرات في طريقه التعامل
مع العمليه او العمليات العسكريه الخاصه
في اوكرانيا امر ضروري
لانه داخل روسيا هناك كثر يقولون ان هذه
العمليه
ليست
الا دفاعيه ليست تحقق النجاحات ويجب على
روسيا ان تعتمد طريقه الهجوم اكثر
نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسيه السابق كان
معنا من موسكو شكرا جزيلا لك
في ردود الفعل الدوليه اجروا وزراء خارجيه
مجموعه السبع مشاورات بشان الوضع في روسيا
يتزمل ذلك مع قلق في بريطانيا من تداعيات
اي تغيير سياسي في روسيا جراء الازمه وفي
واشنطن قال البيت الابيض ان الرئيس جو
بايدن بحث هاتفيا الوضع في روسيا مع نظيره
الفرنسي والمستشار الالماني ورئيس الوزراء
البريطاني واضاف البيت الابيض ان القاده
تاكدوا دعمهم الثابته لاوكرانيا كما تحدث
وزير الدفاع الامريكي
في كندا وفرنسا والمانيا وبولندا
وبريطانيا لبحث الوضع في روسيا وقالت
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه ان اوستن سيبقى
على اتصال مع الحلفاء بشان الوضع في روسيا
افاد مراسل الجزيره بان فريق الامن القومي
الامريكي اطلع الرئيس بايدن ونائبته على
اخر التطورات في روسيا ومن بين المشاركين
في اجتماع البيت الابيض مستشار الامن
القومي ووزير الخارجيه انتوني بلانكن
ووزير الدفاع الى جانب رئيس هيئه الاركان
المشتركه مارك ميلي ومديره الاستخبارات
القوميه ومدير وكاله المخابرات المركزيه
والممثله الامريكيه الدائمه لدى الامم
المتحده ليندا توماس
صرح مسؤولون اسرائيليون لموقع اكسيوس
الاخباريه الامريكي بالقول ان رئيس هيئه
الاركان الامريكيه الغى رحلته الى اسرائيل
التي كان من المقرر ان تبدا يوم الاحد
وانه سيبقى في واشنطن لمتابعه الاحداث
الجاريه في روسيا
هذا وتعتزم الولايات المتحده تاجيل فرض
عقوبات جديده على فاجنر الروسيه خشيه ان
تبدو وكانها تنحاز لاي طرف في الازمه
الروسيه واضافت صحيفه
نقلا عن مصادر ان الخارجيه الامريكيه كانت
تنوي الثلاثاء الاعلان عن عقوبات جديده
على القائمين على اعمال التنقيب عن الذهب
في افريقيا التابعين لفاجنر بما في ذلك
عمليات التنقيب في جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى
ينضم الينا من واشنطن السفير ويليام مساعد
الرئيس كلينتون لشؤون روسيا واوكرانيا
والباحث في مؤسسه راند للدراسات سيد
كورتني مرحبا بك الى اي مدى تعتقد ان ما
حدث خلال الساعات الاربعه والعشرين
الماضيه يمكن ان يدعم التوجه الغربي
لمساعده اوكرانيا في حربها ضد روسيا
في الامن سيدنا رائع اطلاق الحرب كانت
واهيه قال انها اكاذيب من شانها ان تؤدي
الى فقدان الثقه في قياده الكريم بشان
الحرب
وهذا من شانه ان يحبط معنويات عدد من
افراد الجيش الروسي وربما يعطي الافضليه
لاوكرانيا يعني هذه ليست المره الاولى
التي يكذب فيها القاده بشان ان صحت هذا ان
صح هذا الاتهام اصلا من قائد فاجنا التي
يجذب فيها القاده بشان الحروب التي تشنها
بلادهم حدث هذا حتى معلومات المتحده في
العراق وحدث في محطات كثيره من الدول
الكبرى الى اي مدى تعتقد ان هذا يمكن
استغلاله لتقليم اظافر الحمله العسكريه
الروسيه في اوكرانيا كيف
الحرب على العراق ارتكبت الولايات المتحده
خطا بالنسبه الى امتلاك اسلحه الدمار
الشامل حيث تبين ان هذه التقارير كانت غير
صحيحه في هذه الحاله لقد كذب بوتين بشان
وجود قاده نازيين في اوكرانيا ايضا حين
قال
ان الروس في شرق اوكرانيا يتعرضون للقمع
اذا
موضوع احباط معنويات قوات الجيش الروسي قد
يكون اكثر مما كان عليه الامر خلال
الحرب على العراق كيف تفسر عدم قدره
الاستخبارات الغربيه وخصوصا مخابرات
الولايات المتحده عن التنبؤ بحدث بهذه
الضخامه يحدث في دوله تحت المجهر اعني
بذلك روسيا
[موسيقى]
الغرب ليس متفاجئا تماما من ان سيتركين
قد اعلنا على حمله او عن حمله حساسه ضد
وزير الدفاع
وقائد الاركان لانه منذ اشهر يوجه النقد
لهما واكثر من مره صعد في انتقاده وهذا
الاسبوع هذا النقد مباشره ضد بوتين
وبالتالي كان هناك توقع
حول هذا الموضوع لدى الغرب الموقف
الامريكي في اللحظه الراهنه هل تعتقد انه
يعني سيتم استغلال ما حدث خلال الساعات
الاربعه وعشرين والعشرين الماضيه في روسيا
من اجل تطوير
المساعدات التي تقدمها الولايات المتحده
والغرب للقوات الاوكرانيه بعد ان ظهرت على
لسان قائد مجموعه فاجنر ما وصفته انت
بالاكاذيب التي بموجبها تم تسويق هذه
الحرب هل تستغل الولايات المتحده هذا
وتكثف مساعداتها للقوات الاوكرانيه
من المحتمل ان يعزز الغرب هذه المساعدات
العسكريه لاوكرانيا مع انها اصلا ضخمه حتى
الان ولكن طبعا لا شك في ان اوكرانيا
سوف تستمر وربما سنرى الجنود الروس اقل
استعدادنا الان للقتال من اجل الكريم
لانهم سامعوا الان من قائدا معروفين
ومحترم في روسيا يقول ان مبررات الحرب وهي
وهي مجرد ذرائع اذا نحن نتوقع ان ذلك من
شانه ان يحبط معنويات عدد من الروس وسوف
تستغل اوكرانيا ذلك السفير وليم كورتني
مساعد الرئيس كلينتون لشؤون روسيا
واوكرانيا والباحث في مؤسسه راند للدراسات
شكرا جزيلا لك كان معنا من واشنطن منذ
العقد الاول من القرن العشرين وحتى اليوم
شهدت روسيا محطات مفصليه من الثوره
البلشفيه عام 1917 مرورا بانهيار الاتحاد
السوفيتي وصولا الى ما وصفه الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين بتمرد قائد ميليشيا فاجنر
في ذاكره السياسيه ترتبط صوره روسيا
بالقوه العسكريه والتمدد الجيوسياسي الذي
سيطر في ذروه توسع الاتحاد السوفيتي ما
بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه على غالبيه
مساحات اوروبا الشرقيه ووسط اسيا اما
سطوته السياسيه فوصلت الشرق الاوسط
وافريقيا وامريكا اللاتينيه فيما كان يسمى
مره المعسكر الشرقي وما وراء الستار
الحديدي الذي نسجته ضرورات السياسه ما بعد
الحرب العالميه الثانيه تقبع احداث شكلت
او ساهمت في تشكل المشهد الروسي وانهاء
حقب في تاريخ البلاد الحديث
اندلعت الحرب العالميه الاولى وروسيا
قيصريه يحكمها من سيصبح لاحقا قيصر سلاله
رومانوف الاخير نيكولاي تخلفت روسيا
القيصريه حينها عن ركب الثوره الصناعيه
الاوروبيه دخلت الحرب العالميه بازمه
اقتصاديه
واجتماعيه عميقه رافقتها خسائر كبيره على
جبهات القتال بدات بذور ثوره بالتشكل
احتجاجات على نطاق واسع وتظاهرات عماليه
فاضطر القيصر للتنازل عن العرش في مارس
عام
انشا مجلس الدوما حكومه مؤقته كانت اضعف
من ان تقف بوجه ما ستعرف لاحقا بالثوره
البرشفيه ففي اكتوبر من العام نفسه نجح
فصيل من حزب العمل الاشتراكي بقياده
فلاديمير بالاطاحه بالحكومه المؤقته وتشكي
الجمهوريه روسيا الاتحاديه الاشتراكيه وما
بين العامين
1917 و
1922 دخلت البلاد في حرب اهليه لتنتهي
بتشكل الاتحاد السوفيتي توسعت مساحته
بوعيد الحرب العالميه الثانيه واعتبر
حينها احد قطبي العالمي سياسيا استمرت
حياه الاتحاد السوفيتي حتى عام
انذاك شهدت البلاد تمردا هو الثاني منذ
الاطاحه بالقيصر بدا الرئيس السوفيتي
انذاك ميخائيل غورباتشوف ادخال اصلاحات
سياسيه فشكلت مجموعه من الحزب الشيوعي
المعارض لخطوات غورباتشوف لجنه طوارئ
وحاولت الاطاحه به
فاستقال غورباتشوف قررت انهاء عملك رئيس
للاتحاد السوفيتي والغى مكتب رئيس اتحاد
الجمهوريات السوفييتيه وسلم السلطه الى
الرئيس الروسي بوروسيا
اعتبر يلسن ما يجري بمثابه محاوله
الانقلابيه فقمع التحرك بمساعده الجيش
وبلغ الامر قصف مقر مجلس الدومه وحل مجلس
السوفيات الاعلى منهيا بذلك العهد
السوفيتي مرت روسيا بعد انهيار الاتحاد
السوفيتي بسنوات من التغيير السريع
السياسيا واجتماعيا
واقتصاديا عمل الرئيس الحالي فلاديمير
بوتين الذي تولى المنصب بعد يلسن على
اعاده بناء صوره روسيا دوله قويه بجيش قوي
واقتصاد قادر على المنافسه وفي خضم الحرب
على اوكرانيا يتحرك قائد ميليشيا فاجنر
فيما وصفه الرئيس الروسي بنفسه بخيانه
ومحاوله تمرد
روسيا عانت من طعنه مماثله عام 1917 عندما
شاركت بلادنا في الحرب العالميه الاولى
ولكنهم سرقوا منها نصرها ليسجل ليفجين
بيجوشن انه قاد ثالث محاوله تمرد تشهدها
روسيا خلال قرن من الزمن
الكرام وصلنا مع حضراتكم الى ختام حصاد
الليله على مدى الساعتين الماضيتين قدمنا
لحضراتكم تغطيه المتواصله لصعود نظر
الازمه التي شهدتها الاراضي الروسيه ثم
لملمت واحتواء هذه الازمه فيما بدا لنا من
خلال الاتفاق الذي توصل اليه الرئيس
البيلاروسي مع قائد مجموعه فاجن